the time
is 13. clock
hey hey we're here check it out how's it
looking
hopefully it looks okay sound good then
we can hear it let me see if the audio
is good
is the audio working yeah okay
it says the mic's on says the mic song
so we should be good
can everybody hear us somebody hear us i
hope so the first time we've
she's used this program she's like she
learned it in three hours
like today i was just kind of like all
the graphics and everything because like
uh
yeah look it's like check check out also
what i learned to do today this i got
very excited about this look at this
yeah
it's just got like all our instagram and
facebook and it's kind of like that
and it's got all the um patrons names
yeah let that [ __ ] around
i didn't know if it would be like
annoying like that people would be like
hypnotized by it
i was like so excited that i learned it
yeah does it um does it look too bright
or does it or or does the color look
normal
on our on this monitor here it looks
really bright
it doesn't look that bright it doesn't
look bright to me i think you're high
well see look at the difference it looks
more it looks normal here
yeah okay it looks a little bright there
well
could be my settings too that's what i
mean yeah yeah yeah
and it could be my settings because i
think i brightened this up a little bit
because i couldn't see [ __ ]
my settings look pretty good you know
what i mean so everybody says it sounds
good and looks good
all right check it out it's like you
guys i even figured out
how to put kitty videos in here
commercials
commercials all kind of stuff so then if
we have to go to the bathroom you don't
just have to look at empty chairs
so we we have upped our game as promised
i told you that you know [ __ ] if we
if you gave us a good month last month
streaming
that we would [ __ ] upgrade the show
and that we did
and we're gonna [ __ ] improve it even
from here we can we can even improve on
this
now we're working with something yeah
now we're working with something like i
said now if i mess it up don't like get
it because this is literally my first
time live streaming with this
yeah she learned that in three hours so
if i like today i was just like
tearing my hair out like trying to
figure out how this all works because
this is a new this isn't
youtube obviously this is obs yeah uh
which i didn't even know about before
today
so you know yeah and i had to run down
to the damn
what was it best buy to get a damn a
[ __ ] adapter for the land we're we're
not on wireless we're running a lan
cable
yeah because we thought that would
probably be and then of course like when
we got the cable oh man um
we realized that it wouldn't like there
wasn't a port
into the laptop so that would fit so we
had to go get an adapter
yeah had to get it down what is that
thing called a [ __ ]
it's a usb c usb c oh thank you thank
you thank you
they're sending us splash balls somebody
sent us to thank you man thank you
thanks matt
thank you appreciate it he's trying to
move little windows around on this he
said let the games begin
we're gonna get some games tonight i
think it's gonna be a good show
he says what you drinking tom says it's
uh hey that all rhymed
neat it's a tequila this one is uh
cuervo silver uh which is okay i like
cuervo silver it's all right
um cuervo silver with [ __ ] um
[ __ ] rock star just regular rock star
it's good
i used to put a little bit of lime in it
but then i found out it was better
without the lime
yeah yeah it's better without lime just
straight rock star i tried to use some
of that
zero calorie [ __ ] [ __ ] energy drink
it doesn't work man alcohol gets in
there and [ __ ] with those
artificial sweeteners and [ __ ] them all
up they start it starts tasting like
[ __ ] copper or something
i don't know what to tell you man i just
don't terrible it's got to it's got to
be
sugar or it won't work well
i yeah i gotcha
[ __ ] sponsored by the betty 4 clinic
moon pie she won't he [ __ ] bee's nest
wants to see my oh man i totally forgot
to look for a picture of that lady we
got all about moon pie
i'll have to put it in the next one
we'll put them on pie up i mean uh
if you remind me i'll put it in a live
stream tomorrow because i'll find a
picture of her and like put
because i think the only pictures i have
on here i have some kitty videos and i
have some pictures of
our suspects in this program today in
this program you can
[ __ ] load photographs and videos and
and
on command play them and the audience
can see them so it'll be good
yeah yeah let's we'll see how it goes
like i said i hope hopefully i don't
because i have like this big long list
over here and i'm like
clicking through [ __ ] hopefully i don't
click on the wrong thing and like
[ __ ]
i gotta get another splitter so she can
run a mouse off this too because she
right now she's using a damn touchpad
there's not enough damn
ports
two usb ports on laptops nowadays
these do like five of them i know this
this used to be all usb
ports like all along both sides i don't
know why they don't do that
so uh what's the show today today we're
talking about
uh oh she says what program are you
using to live stream
it's a obs it's called
and uh like i said it's open source it's
free i just found out about it today
and um so i watched a couple tutorial
videos on it and then like try to figure
out the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and uh like i said i think i was most
excited about the scrolling
kind of thing at the bottom yeah you
know what i mean that excited me the
most but i was also excited that i could
put like commercials and kitty videos
and stuff because i knew people were
missing those and were missing the intro
and everything
so you know i tried to figure out how to
do it and then tom was like
well we also need like a cool like
waiting video that we can put up that
yeah so i had to make that like really
quick
yeah and i saw you guys commenting on
the waiting that she could
she found some great graphics for and i
thought the music is really good you
guys seem to enjoy it
but when i'm listening to a live stream
i like something to go on during the
waiting period
yeah yeah it's got to fit the show some
some of the guys i was very very happy
because i found that like perfect
like clock video i think it was on vid
easy or something like that yeah
um and i was so excited that i found
just like that free clip and i was like
the guys i listen to man it kind of sets
the tone like you know i mean you know
the show's gonna be good it's like
you're in the theater
you know
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
seeing as the thing is how it's a
cannibal episode what recipes are we
getting tonight
yeah i forgot about this we yeah we
probably gotta
do some recipes yeah we're talking about
the rather thorny issue of
consensual murder and cannibalism
yeah you were telling me about this
earlier now we're actually doing two
cases like the first case is probably
more famous we're talking about that
german dude armin
maives um who uh
found a dude online that was like hey
you can kill and eat me if you want
because okay um but while i was
researching that
i actually found another case uh of a
woman who she didn't want to get eaten
but she wanted to be tortured and
murdered
got some weird [ __ ] and found somebody
i'm like
i don't know it's like here's the thing
i'm really
i'm really like non-judgmental about
people's
sexual fetishes okay you just you do
whatever you
you do you it's none of my business but
the thing about it is that
i don't know i feel like people that
have cannibalism
fetishes because a lot of people do but
they don't actually
want to be eaten i think they just like
to role play
being eaten or like think about being
eaten and that gets them off and
but there is kind of like a small
percentage of hardcore people that
apparently really do want to get eaten
and i'm like well
you know you can only indulge that once
right
yeah i don't care though i guess not
that maybe that's that's like the added
thrill of it
the thing that's getting me is that
you're not going to be around for the
[ __ ] eating part
i don't really it's you yeah that's what
i mean it's like you're going to be
you're just going to be thinking about
it
you're going to get killed well um that
wasn't entirely the case with the
german guy because they did like cut off
a body part oh they did yeah
you can use your imagination which body
part it was and they both tried to eat
it together
damn but that [ __ ] is crazy
yeah it is pretty crazy well the chick
that wanted to be tortured and killed
like
like a serial killer [ __ ] victim
that's some weird [ __ ] there too man
that's [ __ ] get it and it's like you
know what i mean and like i said
i'm i'm not real judgmental about
people's mind because i know some people
have like really weird fetishes and
stuff and i'm just like whatever man as
long as you're not hurting anybody
um but it's like it seems like a really
thorny legal issue
because it's like if somebody said hey
it's okay you can murder me and they
were like in their right mind and
everything
doesn't work that way i guess well no it
doesn't because both of those
both of these people went to prison the
law states the intentional killing of a
person his murder
yeah whether they wanted whether they
were or not yeah did anything to do with
it
yeah i can i can see that that's
probably a good idea because
yeah there are some gray areas with like
assisted suicide but you can still get a
murder charge for that
yeah because that's what i mean it's
kind of like assisted suicide i don't
really have a problem with as long as
like i said as long as the person is
in their right mind and they're like in
a lot of pain and they're not going to
get any better and stuff like that i
don't really have a problem with that
but somebody that's like young and in
good health
and [ __ ] and they just want to do it for
the lulls yeah
or because they think it's like they
think they're depressed
the ultimate high or whatever there's no
hope it's i don't believe in that
because they could change their mind and
it might just need some lithium
or some kind of [ __ ] psychotropic
drug snapping out of it there are a lot
of people are mentally ill
when they're off their medication they
want to die but when they're on it
they're all right
yeah you know what i mean so
yeah what are you doing pope knock it
off
sandra sanders says i don't even want to
touch most people i see let alone eat
them
right i know yeah and i mean you know i
guess you could do
like you could pull a survivor type uh
like like he's saying in the comments
where you could just do it finger here
and a toe there
which you know if you were into that but
i think the thing about armin maivas in
particular
was that he had had fantasies from when
he was a kid of
eating a person um just like
consuming them whole he had the same
kind of thing as jeffrey dahmer where
he wanted to eat them because then they
would be a part of him forever
you know what i mean yeah he had the
similar kind of uh
you know it seems like he had this
similar kind of psychology
and you know a similar kind of
upbringing yeah it's not true though
well no yeah yeah but they for some
reason [ __ ] a lot of them out
that's where they get the idea from oh
my goodness what is up with this
you can [ __ ] a lot of them out whatever
protein you synthesize off of them
is going to go into a cell and that cell
might not be you might only be in your
body for you know
three or four months before it's
replaced by another cell you know
i don't know how how long the average
cell lives somebody could find out but
it's not long i think it's
yeah i don't think it's that long i
think it's in months
yeah yeah what are you doing knock it
off
come here come here goodness it's not
like having a little kid she comes
here oh okay she was there was some
tinfoil over there yes she's like
[ __ ] boys she doesn't like that we're
not paying attention to her yeah but she
doesn't you know she comes in the room
and she's just like [ __ ]
i don't know it's crazy but um i don't
think we have any particular
shout outs today like i don't think we
had any new patrons this week because
because you know that's sad but you know
now that we had some or no we haven't
had any patrons this week i said
okay um to give like
shout outs to um
other than that like i think like i
mentioned this on one of our other live
streams but
uh my book review show i'm gonna start
putting those up
on uh monday august 31st and i think i'm
gonna put one up every monday so
there'll be one every week
like i said i already have a couple
recorded and uh i get pokey
yeah oh you're so cute baby girl
i'm just sidetracked from the show
i know every time i see her i'm just
like i'm trying to keep her quiet she's
yeah
she's attacking and biting everything
yeah because she's like wanting us to
to get to play with me i'm gonna make
noise until you do she was just she just
woke up
she's just sleeping on a bed yeah she's
been sleeping all day we got her a
little uh
water fountain yeah yeah she likes it
she was kind of scared of it at first
like when we first plugged it in because
it was kind of loud like we've turned it
down now so it's not as loud
but she was like looking at it going
what what is that
and then she's like looking at she's
like sticking her paw in the water like
yeah she got a drink
i mean i hope she likes it because like
i said i'm not we're not always up to
like turn she likes to drink out of the
bathroom sink but we're not always up to
like turn the
bathroom sink on for her to drink out of
it
but yeah so uh so yeah i'm gonna start
putting up uh book reviews every monday
starting august 31st because i already
have some done and i figured it was dumb
to like wait all the way until halloween
um because i've already got a few weeks
ahead so
that'll be something to look forward to
if you're into like horror books and
[ __ ] like that and want to hear me yak
about them
then uh you know yeah every time i puke
it'll be right up your alley
i know see yeah michael's talking about
general so's
pookie's the star general so's tom i'm
not really sure what you're talking
about general so
are we talking about eating people yeah
we can make general says chicken out of
you
i love general cells i make it i can
make it here
you make a lot of good stuff you make a
lot of good chinese all that chinese is
easy to make
well it's only like a handful of
different sauces
you know what i mean it's kind of like
once you like
it's like you an indian food it's like
once you know like the spice ratios for
different things it's like mostly the
same spices or the same ingredients just
in different
proportions some of that stuff that you
know can be done in different ways you
know like uh
like get a [ __ ] like the beef based
ones
with the with the gravy they have a
couple different ways that they do that
one
but all the sweet and sour ones are
pretty much the same
you know um you might be able to
substitute a couple of things but that's
just so easy yeah
yeah it's basically pineapple juice
ketchup
pretty much and uh sugar and uh vinegar
you know you just have to do it the
right way mm-hmm and the batter we're
gonna make everybody hungry at least
yeah
yeah at least until we start talking
about
eating people's penises
you've actually gotten a lot better
since our uh necrophilia show
yeah when you when you like had a
tantrum and like left
cannibalism though is a lot different
than negative it is [ __ ] terrible
really terrible it is at least with
pookie
leave it alone he's trying to attack the
aluminum foil
okay that's it i gotta take it no oh no
oh no she's getting it taken away
she's gonna take it away you're in
trouble yeah you're trouble now
what was why was that over there oh
cause i guess that was uh that was my
reflector
for the reflector for the uh light bulb
for the shooting the
screens for the t-shirts yeah every time
you guys get talking about cannibals you
start talking about food
yeah well it's hard not to i mean well
at least
humans are made of meat so at least with
cannibalism it's fresh it's not rotten
and the idea of you know you're making
having sex with somebody who's down
rotten i just know i
ain't going for that man yeah yeah well
yeah i mean
on on the spectrum of grossness i think
i'd much rather eat a person than have
sex with a dead person
i mean that's there'd be a wide gap but
the cannibalism angle to me isn't isn't
too gross
well like i said it's meat yeah yeah i
mean
cannibalism for survival and stuff that
doesn't really as long as it's being
prepared properly and you know nobody
was really kind of murdered for it
yeah if you're seeing somebody that is
just right they just kind of died from
but it's like that [ __ ] that's weird
where you know like a kid a guy will
abduct some kid
if i can rape him and kill him and then
turn him into chili and feed him back to
the [ __ ]
search party or that remember the dude
that
fed the kid to uh to the people at the
chili contest
yeah that's actually yeah we might did
we talk about
it yeah and that kids relatives and
friends were in the crowds
it was you know that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
pretty damn sick yeah
not really gross just evil yeah yes me
evil yeah
chaz wants to know why pookie is more
popular than beijing
doesn't want to be [ __ ] with a man
she's weird beijing
she well she's an older kid i mean she's
not old but she's 10 or 11.
yeah about that and um she's like
whereas pookie is very much like uh
wanting to
always be up in your face and she's just
kind of like a little tomboy all the
time she's like wait what are you doing
what are you doing she always wants to
help out
beijing is kind of like yeah get away
from me
if you start petting her she starts
complaining yeah
what's wrong then she goes
she'll hiss because she's but what's
funny is that she's acting like she's
enjoying it
it's weird she's like yeah pet me pet me
but then she's complaining all these
mixed signals
yeah when i got pookie
beijing got pissed off she's jealous of
poop she's still mad about it three
years later
yeah so she she blames me for poogie
yeah you know because i brought pookie
in the house so she blames me
yeah and she still has not she's she she
can uh carry a grudge
apparently forever because she's still
mad at us for breeding pookies
even though she plays with pokey they
didn't used to they used to fight all
the time but the funny thing about it is
that
beijing knows because for some reason
pookie likes to jump on her butt
i guess because her butt's so fluffy and
it's just like she can't resist it
so it's like whenever beijing goes out
on the porch like pookie will like sit
there and wait
like i'll crouch down and then beijing's
like oh [ __ ] i gotta
run the gauntlet and then she tries to
jump past but pookie's like
then she like jumps on her she knows
you're talking about it
she rolled over on her back she's
rolling over on her back
oh my goodness she's watching you talk
about her you're so funny she's [ __ ]
hilarious
she knows her name yeah so whenever we
talk about her she's like whoa
yeah i've never seen had a cat like that
that cat's a lot like a monkey
a lot like a monkey crossing a monkey
and a dog and a bear
and a person
but yeah so uh like i said we don't have
um
uh any other shout outs i don't think
not that i can think of anyway
so maybe we should start talking about
the cannibalism
it's like that's the only thing though
about streaming from
this program is that i don't know
i have to keep going back and forth to
see how long it's been on
you know what i mean because i don't
know like the time yeah
oh well i mean i guess it doesn't matter
we'll figure it out that is that one is
that window still
running it looks frozen to me well it's
just nobody is
necessarily um
comment it i don't think beijing is
beautiful yes yes
yeah uh oh somebody says a favorite
flick of mine is the ass fix i have seen
that
actually i wrote um a big long thing
about it on my blog like several years
ago
it's a really weird movie it's like a
british um
it's almost like a frankenstein type
story but then it's almost kind of like
the aspects is like this thing that
comes and gets your soul like when you
die
it's like a greek mythology thing and so
it has this guy who's like a scientist
and he's trying to like
capture people's ass fixes
yeah whatever yeah it's kind of obscure
but um i don't remember how i ended up
seeing it i think i saw it on some
like underrated horror list or something
like that and i ended up watching it and
i really liked it like i wrote
um like a big long thing about it for my
blog like a while back
so uh amazingly i have seen that movie
and i quite enjoyed it i like a lot of
british horror movies
all right so uh let's talk about
armin vivez myviz i guess is how you
pronounce it
um i was watching this one there's a
documentary
called i think it's called the man who
ate his lover
and it was like a i don't know it was
bbc or something like that but i watched
that one and that's how they pronounced
it so that's how i'm gonna pronounce
yeah i used reverse psychology on her
yeah i shut the door so she wanted out
she's like oh my god i'm jumping in here
now oh [ __ ]
yeah so there you go that's pretty funny
[Laughter]
all right so old arm and myvis
now he was born in 1961 in essen
germany now apparently uh
he was kind of a lonely kid kind of an
introverted
kid um ooh who this
oh thank you nico yes you can yes you
can what is it what is it
can i get another shirt in 3xl the 2x
was a bit too snug sure i can do that no
yeah just make sure we have your
information right i yeah i do yeah yeah
let me write that down right there
which one do you want stay blessed
or one with the logo on it i'm not
really sure all right yeah if you guys
want any shirts just you can pay us here
we can get your information you can send
it to jenny
and uh we'll ship them out in a couple
days i'll make you some more yeah
because i just i
have some blanks and yeah i think i have
a couple other ones
um so yeah he was uh so he grew up in
this family like his dad
uh took off when our when armin was
eight and
his mother and i think this was kind of
the case with jeffrey dahmer as well his
mother was real like domineering
and super i mean what you have here is
another kind of like psycho situation
where the mom is basically just like
smothering
the kid like he didn't want like she
didn't want him
having friends she didn't want him going
out with girls she didn't want him doing
anything like that so it's like they had
this really weird
like symbiotic relationship and they
lived in this
giant house it was like a big mansion
um and they pretty much both lived in
there together
and you know had just this weird i don't
know it was really messed up
so it seems that armin had
kind of a um cannibal thing
from a pretty young age so
he ends up he was really into hansel and
gretel
um and the witch like eating
the kids you know what i mean he was
really into that
now he was also like i said he was
really lonely he didn't really have any
siblings
so he invented an imaginary brother
that he named frankie and
he would like have these fantasies where
him and frankie would like
go out in the woods and like he they
would like eat their friends
damn like you know what i mean yeah and
it was it was very funny because
the um the documentary that they had
about him the man who eddie's lover
they had like these little animated
sequences
of like his childhood fantasies and they
were really
[ __ ] up but they were really kind of
funny because they were just like these
little black shadow figures
like little kids and they're out in the
woods and then there'd be another they
looked a little bit like edward gory
actually and he would like go over to a
friend and like
pull his head off and then just put his
whole head in his mouth and then the
head would be in his stomach it was like
really
weird but it's like they were kind of
cute too
so um so his mom didn't really seem to
know that he had kind of this active
fantasy life going on
but uh you know as i said him and his
mom had a really like weirdly
close relationship that said like a lot
of the neighbors
they talked to some of the neighbors on
this documentary as well
and they knew him and they just thought
he was a really nice
kid like they didn't think they said he
was a little weird like a little shy
and stuff like that but not you know
that there wasn't anything
all that unusual about him sounds like
when he's a sheltered guys
he was yeah he never really did anything
on his own
under his mama's [ __ ] ape and strings
yeah
now he did actually um join the army
for a time and it seems like
a lot of the guys like because a lot of
the kids where he grew up like they were
they were interviewing a couple kids
that had grown up in the same
you know they're grown people now but
there were kids at the time they were
the same age as him that had grown up on
the same street
and they said you know it's like he
wasn't a bad guy or like
all that weird but it's like he didn't
really he's like you know when all of us
like turned 15 16 started dating going
out to bars and
discus because germany you can go out to
discos and chill like that when you're
15 or 16 years old
and it's like he didn't really ever want
to do that he was always just kind of
staying in the house with his mom
so they thought that was a little
strange well hold on this is germany
right
yeah they have mandatory service he
didn't join he was drafted
yeah but i think he didn't i mean he
didn't mind going yeah i guess
well he's probably trying to get out of
the house he sounds like
just kind of one of those sheltered
introverted
shy yeah he definitely was his mind was
running away with him
and his mom would basically i mean it
seemed like when he got out of school
like one thing he actually did get
really into was like sailing
so he made these friends that had a
sailboat and he would like go out on
uh trips with them like go on sailing
trips and things and he was really good
you know with with the boat and like he
learned knew everything about the boat
and [ __ ]
but they said that every time they went
on a trip
um you know that was more than a day or
two
like he had to call his mom like all the
time because she was always like where
are you what are you doing what
she was she was like really really it
sounded like she was
she was afraid of abandonment yeah did
his dad leave
yeah yeah that's what it was yeah the
dad's afraid he was gonna leave yeah the
dad left when
armin was eight years old yeah so she
had abandonment
issues yeah so she wanted to keep the
kid like
close by here that's what was going on
there sandra says you can choose between
army or community service
in germany so you don't have to go in
the army but you have to do one or the
other
i'd recommend army if you're a guy
i love the army well it's like
well it's the thing is what you don't
well i guess you wouldn't know
if you joined the army what you'd be
doing but if you did community service
you don't know what you'd be doing
either
i would have volunteered for infantry
just like i did
that's the fun [ __ ] yeah yeah fun and
hard
elsa says i'm an only child 32 years old
and my mom kind of expects to talk to me
every day on the phone
yep which i don't know like i i
had three siblings so your
parents are not as up your butt all the
time
yeah about everything like it's now it's
like i love my
mom but um you know i probably only
write to her
or call her like every few weeks or
something
and like sometimes she'll send me an
email and be like hey what's going on
you know what i mean
so it's not like which is bad because
it's like if i got murder or something
like they wouldn't know for like a
really long time probably
and i haven't talked to my dad for like
forever i don't even remember the last
time that was
but yeah so she's definitely like a a
smothering kind of i don't think she was
abusive or anything
but she just seemed like she didn't want
him to
live a normal life what you're talking
about is it talking about
like sonia that's what they're talking
about
yeah yeah or france sonia it's like
got a daughter and that that daughter is
like a [ __ ] baby doll
and that kid's probably i don't even
remember how old that kid is she's gotta
be in
got to be 12 years old by now 13.
probably yeah yeah it's been a while
since we saw her
yeah it's just i don't know it's very
strange to me because
yeah it's kind of strange i mean i guess
i'm getting you know i was the oldest
but i was only
you know my my parents only kid for four
years because my brother was born when i
was four
so it's like they had enough kids and
and they didn't didn't have a lot of
money so they had a lot more problems to
worry about than like wondering what the
[ __ ] i was up to all the time
and i was a good kid we were all good
kids so we weren't really
running around doing [ __ ] we didn't not
most of the time anyway
except for my brother he was around
blowing stuff up but
most of the time we weren't doing
anything we weren't supposed to do
so yeah so he goes in the army and they
interviewed like some of the people that
had
served with him and they just said
that um one guy said that he
that armin had asked him if he's like do
you
think that i come across as gay
the thing about him is i don't think he
was gay i think he was bisexual
um was he's still alive as far as i know
but i think that he didn't really have i
mean this wasn't
you know this was in the 90s 2000 so
it's not like it was that
weird it's not like he was you know it
was like the [ __ ] 50s or 60s and
everyone was like
would stone you to death or anything
like that but it really did seem like he
was kind of sheltered so he didn't
really have a frame of reference really
but he did kind of ask like the other
dudes that he was in the army with
like do i come across as gay to you i
think he was gay
every guy i've ever known has ever asked
that was gay
well they're just like asking it's like
justin gay to you
[Laughter]
yeah you do
like toby yeah totally yeah
i seem gay to you and i was like no man
[Laughter]
no man he knows he's gay though not at
all man
you're all man oh man he's if you guys
don't know who i'm talking about
my buddy [ __ ] toby's a [ __ ]
leather daddy he's he's rob
halford style gay you know kind of like
a [ __ ]
warrior [ __ ] man warrior masculine
gay
yeah but for some reason he doesn't want
to [ __ ] be gay or he doesn't want to
be seen as gay
yeah it's it's just a
well he idolized he idolized his [ __ ]
masculinity
you know manliness he didn't like
effeminate
guys so do i seem gay to you
but i know him you know yeah and i'm
thinking myself yeah
yeah you seem kind of good
not in a bad way
but yeah i mean they do think that armin
went to
like female prostitutes um
but there were also rumors that i don't
think i don't know if he'd had like
sexual relationships with any of the
other guys in the army but there was
like rumors that like he had kissed some
of their one of them or
something like that so there were kind
of rumor swirling and he did kind of ask
about it he didn't seem to get picked on
about it or anything
but it just was something that was uh
commented upon
so germany was progressive back in those
days well like i said this wasn't
i mean this wasn't that long ago yeah
you know
so he i mean he was born in 61 so he's
not that he wasn't that old back when i
was in you know
in the [ __ ] 90s was under the don't
ask don't
tell policy which was progressive for
the for those
days you could be gay you just weren't
supposed to be out or open with it
you know we all know who the goo who was
gay though
it was obvious you know yeah it didn't
make a difference
i mean sometimes it's not but a lot of
we pretty much knew who it was
yeah yeah it didn't really fit as long
as you know they didn't [ __ ] with you
you know well yeah they mess with you
they mess with each other
i pretty much like any that's i don't
care what they were underground
there were underground gay bars in the
area and they all knew each other from
those [ __ ] bars and those clubs yeah
so you know what i mean they kind of had
their own thing going on but if
you know if you weren't if you weren't
going to those clubs i guess
you were off limits so they didn't [ __ ]
with you well yeah they don't want to
get in trouble
you want to get in trouble you might get
kicked out yeah yeah so you know you can
see yeah
which you know didn't bother us yeah we
didn't care
yeah that's what i mean it's like it's
not really it's not anyone's business i
don't know and
as far as i understand as far as i
understood it
not karen went way back for the most
part
yeah yeah the the don't ask don't tell
thing
what came out nowadays they say that
that wasn't good enough
you know they would say oh that's
[ __ ] bigoted or something but in the
day that don't ask don't tell thing was
[ __ ] uh
was basically permission yeah you could
serve
that's what that's that's what it was
for yeah because before then
all's it took was you could be suspect
and they'd kick you and they'd kick you
out yeah right well guess what
that was a good way of getting rid of
your competition
see if the guy was in in in in your way
for promotion
you could always [ __ ] go and go to
[ __ ] cid or whatever your chain of
command goes
that [ __ ] tried to kiss me and
then they would just kick him
and kick his ass out yeah
see that's they'd kick his ass out and
then you'd get the promotion
like that see people think people
people think that the world is honest
it's not [ __ ] honest and the army
wasn't honest he had to keep it honest
it was [ __ ]
the army was not a [ __ ] fish tank it
was a shark tank there were no fish left
it was just sharks
yeah and promotion
you know dudes are sometimes fought
dirty is dishonorable but we knew who
they were
yeah we knew who the [ __ ] spot who
the snakes were
you know and you know eventually they
got theirs
because there were ways yeah you need
guys in the service no i'm talking about
there were ways there are ways to get
even
yeah which you know i i hope that does
happen because i do feel like people
that do horrible things like get away
with it a lot of the times yeah
[Laughter]
yeah saunders says we already had a lot
of gay clubs here in the 90s and
straight clubs which had gay nights once
or twice a month
it's like i feel like we had that too
but i think we were kind of like behind
in the sense of like people being
accepting of them you know what i mean i
think it depended on the generation
well it depended on where it was i mean
big cities were obviously a lot more
accepting than opening up a place in
like bum [ __ ] oklahoma
big cities in the 70s were off the chain
evidently they were just oh yeah
you know they were david bowie to the
[ __ ] max
they were bullied the [ __ ] out but you
know the rest of the united states you
can you can do that [ __ ] in mississippi
yeah you get your ass get your ass
whipped yeah and
it's not like they didn't they didn't
[ __ ] it's not like they were saying
that
that you couldn't exist or you couldn't
live you just couldn't exist
there they wanted you to go yeah go
somewhere else it was
this it was a self-segregating
population
a lot of the united states was like that
back in the day i mean even in the late
80s
i mean i knew guys that you know weren't
even gay but they just like looked out
there wore eyeliner or something like
that and they got you
[ __ ] they got beat up so you know but
like i said
what was funny i grew up in daytona
beach florida which
what was funny is that the dudes that
were [ __ ] most likely to beat up on
some dude was wearing eyeliner because
he thought he was gay
was a big old [ __ ] macho dude that
was [ __ ] probably gay
or was worried that he might be worried
that he couldn't yeah well yeah because
like
like i said otherwise he's attracted
you're i'm attracted to you i'm a beat
your ass
exactly because why would you care
otherwise you cute [ __ ] i gotta
kill you
you keep [ __ ] that's what it is
it has to be that because like i said a
normal person would just
like they wouldn't give a [ __ ] wouldn't
give a [ __ ] you know what i mean
you're embarrassing me in front of my
friends
[Laughter]
honestly i think that's what it is yeah
i think i thought so too
i mean because remember i was looking
good man so i'd get that reaction
sometimes i was like what are you trying
to kick my ass for i don't [ __ ] know
you dude
you're giving me a boner my friends are
noticing that i'm looking at you
oh i'm sure i'm sure that's exactly what
it is [ __ ] right yeah [ __ ] high
school [ __ ]
for all i know you go back go back 10
years later that might focus on the gay
bar
yeah he finally decided yeah just just
let it right be himself
man just do it yeah all right yeah
the team's not around anymore i can
relax
coach said it was all right
i just had a flashback to that [ __ ]
scene in heather's i love my dad gay son
all right so anyway we should probably
review heather's one of these days if
it's not a horror movie it's a black
comedy but still
so uh armin gets out of the army armin
was in the army that's funny
and um he actually becomes a computer
technician now according to his
neighbors
he was really really good at building
computers fixing computers [ __ ] like
that
he was like he would fix all their
computers
you know because that's what happens
when you're good at something everybody
just wants you to do it and you can't
ever get a moment's piece
that seems like what happened to him
because it's like his neighbors were
just like every time my computer crashed
they'd like call him up and he'd have to
come over and fix it
so um so like i said he was still going
to prostitutes
um i don't know if he really had any
kind of um
you know out gay relationships or
anything at this point
but it does seem like he was still very
introverted he still
um stayed at home with his mother most
of the time she didn't really like him
to go anyplace
so he was kind of stuck around the house
like i said it's a big giant house it's
a mansion
pretty much i think it's abandoned now
because i think when i was
uh the video that came up after the um
the documentary about him was a was an
uh urban exploration
of his abandoned mansion and i don't
know how old it was it wasn't that old i
don't think it was just like a year or
two so i guess it's still there but it's
abandoned
so he's just like hey check it out this
is where the guy got murdered probably
and all this other stuff so it was
pretty weird
uh yeah so you all right
you look like your soul's leaving your
body already i was belching
[Laughter]
i want you okay no no i'm good oh i was
gonna say
no all the tacos there's two tacos i ate
yeah i
made some bad ass [ __ ] tacos they
were really i made that i made the
[ __ ] corn tortillas they weren't
penis tacos no not penis tacos
chicken tacos with black beans on them
and
um cream cheese with homemade salsa
yeah they were delicious yeah pico de
gallo actually wasn't missiles it was
pico de gallo as well yeah
and then i put some that damn [ __ ]
mayan
mayan have [ __ ] narrow hot sauce on
there
i can't even or something
that's what it's called any mayans can
like let us say mine's made that [ __ ]
it'll [ __ ] burn you up man make you
cut a motherfucker's heart out
i would have liked the worst heartbreak
getting better at making those corn tea
those corn tortillas though
[Laughter]
getting drunk yeah i mix my drinks a lot
stronger than hers so
i go down first i start [ __ ]
i start faltering but i'm i'm listening
to this i'm listening to her
tell this story i'm trying to i'm trying
to um give you guys my
my analysis yeah yeah on those on this
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] on this monster here
so all right
so so he is uh
going into like chat rooms he discovers
chat rooms internet kind of [ __ ] and he
finds out that there's a whole community
of people
who are into this cannibal fetish like
he is
so as i said most of the people on these
just have like fantasies about eating
people they wouldn't
really do it or you know what i mean i
just think they like thinking about it
like i wonder how many guys just
fantasize about being a serial killer
but never do it
um i imagine it's a lot and i really
would rather not know because i'm sure
it's like
an alarming amount if there are if there
are guys fantasizing about just eating
people then that means
that means a serial killer element must
be even bigger that's what i'm saying
because that's more common than cannibal
yeah
well i mean you have to think that it's
all going to be on a continuum right and
it's like
and i'm not saying that it's bad to have
fantasies about
killing people or something like that
because a lot of people do i think most
people do
well somebody makes you mad you would
now i would cut that motherfucker's head
i would stomp him i would stomp that
[ __ ] into a greasy spot
you know and [ __ ] like that yeah and i
think pretty much everything because
it's an [ __ ] you know yeah
yeah and i mean i you know i've thought
that just about some [ __ ] in the
grocery store that was pissing me off
you know it was just like a dead dude
with a sledgehammer
like like a donkey kong yeah that's like
a donkey
so the fact that you know probably 99.99
of the people in the world have had a
fantasy about killing somebody
just not that they would really do it
obviously but just it makes you feel
better because the dude's being a dick
right
so you know a slightly smaller asp
you know like uh percentage of that
would be
people fantasizing about killing
multiple people
and maybe killing people they don't know
or people that aren't even doing
anything or people that just like
wandered right past
you know what i mean i definitely think
like as as far as male fantasies go i
think probably
fantasies about raping someone is way
more
um prevalent than killing somebody but
i don't know i don't know i don't think
so i think killing somebody's
probably more maybe more yeah because
most guys are probably thinking about
i'm gonna kill that [ __ ] that
dude
yeah so it's not sexual motive at all
yeah just i hate that dude i'm gonna
kill it
that's probably a lot more common yeah
maybe i never saw some woman go i'ma
rape that
you know i hope not oh that would like
really scare me if i thought i think uh
i think i'm pretty average on that on
that spectrum i don't think guys think
that way
yeah they would have told me if they did
because you know i had some [ __ ] a
lot of close friends they never
mentioned that
yeah but they were all successful with
women
or if i wouldn't i didn't [ __ ] with them
if they couldn't get women but so maybe
that's what
so it was a self-selecting like
population maybe if you hung out with a
bunch of losers it might be different
then
you know what i mean that couldn't get
girlfriends yeah then maybe you would
have had a different experience maybe
but i don't know i don't think so i'd
have been a remember to read it in dudes
and
most dudes don't seem to really give a
[ __ ] too much you know
not to burst a woman's bubble well no i
was like i hope not because i'd be like
i'd be [ __ ] scared walking around
most guys don't really give a [ __ ] too
much about women all the time they're
mostly
you know believe it or not guys care
more about things like cars and
motorcycles than they do
people and women yeah they were like
that's a [ __ ] badass motorcycle
god damn look at that thing wonder what
the displacement is on that [ __ ] look at
that [ __ ] back tire
god damn you never hear a man talk about
a woman that way no you don't
no more is the pity no it's the [ __ ]
he's freaking out over
this yeah dudes are like way more
inanimate in general right yeah in
general now he might
see some woman walk by go god damn you
see that [ __ ] ass on her jeez yeah
cause i've seen you and
leave the ball yeah yeah yeah goddamn
like
the motorcycle thing will stick with you
the woman will
the the the image will the butt is
fleeting the butt is free
you'll be like yeah yeah
then you'll agree on it yeah yeah and
then it's over
that's a good one that's it you see it
happen
i mean and me and lee we we both had
girlfriends but it's
it's just an irresistible urge it's
it's a testosterone fueled [ __ ] it's
a hormonal thing it's kind of like women
looking at a baby going oh isn't that
cute you know what i mean and then
that's it
god didn't give a [ __ ] about the baby
but women are like oh that's babies
that's a cute baby
you know i don't like babies what was it
well whenever somebody brings a baby
like doesn't like to a family gathering
i'm like please god please
let them not give it to me
because i'm gonna drop it and it's gonna
puke on me or some [ __ ] like that
yeah but now that's another thing
another thing is is that you know
i'm going to give my word to the female
audience out there as a man
as a bonafide card carrier man
it's not the average female
feature that sticks out guys are into
novelty it's something that stood out
from the crowd
and it usually has to do with the size
yeah
you know what i mean how big those booty
how big that chest was that kind of [ __ ]
that's all
yeah and then it's then it's fleeting
like you said it's quickly forgotten
so it's like a novelty thing yeah you
know if it's not really a novelty then
it doesn't really it you don't
differentiate too much
you know and it doesn't impress a man
that much
i guess yeah yeah it doesn't not really
it's just notable it's like did you know
that
yeah yeah i'm gonna write that down
right
yeah it's just notable that's the only
way i can describe it
that's a very funny word i don't know
why
thank you larry i don't know why that
the use of that particular word made me
laugh
but you know it's notable it might be
legs or it might be something you know
it just depends but like i said
most dudes are not going to be fixed on
it like oh i got oh that's it i got to
rape her
i'm following her that's it it's over
with
i'm going to kill her that's it that's
just not normal
although well yeah thankfully but like i
said um
it does happen sometimes because thank
you very much larry larry laugh
because like i said you know sometimes
when i used to
uh you know have to leave the house to
go to work
and uh i'd be in the 7-eleven next to
work getting a cup of coffee in the
morning
and some dude to be in there like
cornering
by the coffee machine wanting to talk to
me and i'm just like dude i'm just
trying to get my coffee back off
yeah but see louis hernandez is saying
tom's right i saw ss camaro it's either
71 or 72
i know the [ __ ] car i know the
[ __ ] car with the hood
graphics and everything i know what
you're talking about with the [ __ ]
bat
[ __ ] fender swells the [ __ ] the
back fenders on that [ __ ] car was
[ __ ] bad ass
i know that car that's crazy good car he
said he's still thinking about that car
yeah guys are so funny
yeah they just get so excited about yeah
those rare quarter
rear quarter panels on that car [ __ ]
does this they just look badass
and [ __ ] they're stupid not to remake
that a camaro shaped like that in the
way that ford
did a mustang that was kind of shaped
like the 64 and a half
mustang they kind of brought that back
man [ __ ]
they need to bring back that [ __ ]
chevy camaro that looked like that 71.
yeah he knows what i'm talking about
hernandez knows what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about
that's the way a camaro is supposed to
look not these [ __ ]
sharp [ __ ] angular wedge [ __ ]
things no
a masculine bulbous thing
that looked like it damn came out of a
foreskin that's where that [ __ ] car
is supposed to look
a rolling penis phallic symbol
out of [ __ ] my way get out of my way
when you're driving it doesn't have to
look fast it just has to look
plump
i just had a really really funny mental
picture
yeah of someone could be you uh
walking down the street with your dick
out like pushing people yeah yeah you
get out of my way
it's like you just backhanded a [ __ ]
out of your way with that car
and it was a slow car but it's a [ __ ]
slow car
by today's standards that [ __ ] was slow
as [ __ ] oh man you're making me laugh so
my eyes are watering
but that little nissan altima you had
would outrun that [ __ ] 71 stock
probably but it was just it just looked
like it was my nissan altima was like
super fast
and that little [ __ ] ford fan yeah i
had a honda fit
that was really fast i looked down i was
going up two and 110 miles
110 in this thing i told you it didn't
weigh anything and like a few times like
when i was driving it i'd be driving it
over like an overpass and it'd be really
windy and i for real thought that car
was just going to blow off the [ __ ]
overpass
because it felt like it was shoe those
old 70 cars just the way they were you
know the old v8 american v8s they just
sounded like they'd kill you
looked at me like was he making that
noise he was like daddy right
it just sounded like they were just
going to [ __ ] eat you alive
you know but stock there wasn't anything
there you really had to do a lot of work
on them and
breaks sucked and handling sucked we're
getting on the cars now well i remember
you
they were from another era and they were
built cheaply too they really had that
old ford mustang
yeah that that ford mustang had a nice
body and a nice interior and everything
but that was a 3.8 motor it wasn't the
[ __ ] great motor i had
divorced divorced dual [ __ ] shorty
thrush thrush [ __ ] baffled mufflers
kind of like magnaflows on there
that thing sounded like a damn b-17
bomber man
i know i had to drive it one time when
my car was in the shop like after i got
in a wreck and like
[ __ ] it was it was heavy and it was
like
you it i felt like you had to push the
gas pedal all the way down like to get
it to go
yeah to 60. it sounded like it was going
real
fast it felt like it was [ __ ] going
fast too and you'd look down you go like
man i'm only going 95.
that little honda fit i was doing 110
miles an hour drunk on the way back from
tampa i looked down like whoa
one damn we'll see i told you i felt
like i was just standing still
yeah i used to work late at night and i
was always um you know i'd have to drive
from orlando back to daytona like two or
three in the morning
and there was nobody on the road like to
compare my speed to
yeah so i'd just be driving down the
street i was sober and i was just like
driving let's listen to my music waiting
to go home and [ __ ] like that i'm like
oh [ __ ] i'm going to earn 20 months ago
yeah
shhh it wasn't quick but it was
fast i mean it would get the hot the the
uh
you do it like 110 120 without liking it
going slow
and that to do 110 and that old [ __ ]
sn95 an sn94 mustang it would have felt
like you were breaking the [ __ ]
sound barrier
you you and chuck yeager is just
strapped in
all right we're getting ready to [ __ ]
break your
yeah face we go we'll be there in a
minute
whoa a hundred yeah and the [ __ ] car
is going
like it's going breaking a hole through
the space-time continuum and [ __ ]
they just weren't fast and they it was a
lot of mass
and they didn't handle all that well
but you can make these newer cars look
as cool
as those old 70s cars if you [ __ ]
knew what you were doing you could make
it look really cool
the styling departments now they they
worry too much about aerodynamics
thank you matt thank you very much
they're worried too much about
aerodynamics and
economy and all that [ __ ] you know what
i mean [ __ ] that man just make this [ __ ]
look cool
just make it look cool instead of my old
jeep i felt like i was in a bratwurst
[Laughter]
all right so uh so like i said
armin still kind of a shy dude so he's
very
into the internet very into all these
like weird chat rooms
getting uh you know together with other
people with cannibalistic type of
fantasies
so he decides that he is gonna post an
ad
for somebody um for a willing
victim who is willing to be killed
and eaten now the funny thing is that
you would think
that nobody would answer that but you
would be wrong
he actually had more than one person
answer it but i guess he was like kind
of going through
i think a couple of the people that
answered it um
you know kind of backed out at the last
minute because they're like oh [ __ ] uh
this is death that i'm talking about and
getting eaten so then they chickened out
uh but one guy one guy did not so he
writes this ad
and um he puts it under the name
frankie which was the name that he used
for
oh thank you thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
he puts it under the name frankie which
was the name of
the uh imaginary kid brother that he had
so he basically says in this ad that
he's looking for
a well-built man
well-built man you'd think you want a
fat dude
more meat on them yeah i mean if you're
going to eat them you might as well
he's talking about muscles and muscle
and teletubbies
yeah yeah i know it's just funny he's
getting bomber
getting damn wrong he wants to be enough
flesh there to eat and nobody wants to
he wants it to be kind of lean you know
i mean you have to say though it's like
that this dude
he had dahmer tendencies but at least i
mean dahmer was killing people that
didn't say hey it's okay you can kill me
at least this guy
i'm not saying it's good i'm just saying
that at least he only killed one person
and that one person was like yeah it's
totally fine
that's some weird [ __ ] man which that's
a weird [ __ ] just scared people
that was like chicken that was just that
was his that was his [ __ ] sexual
fantasy was to be killed and eaten yeah
so apparently that's a thing
that some people have that yeah so uh
so yeah like i said he he had several
replies to this
post uh but almost all of them
uh chickened out at the last minute um
and he didn't like pursue them or
anything he was just like you know
that's fine that's understandable
however one dude decided he was gonna go
through with this this dude was named
bernd brandes
now he was from uh berlin and he was an
engineer
and the funny thing about him was that
they interviewed like a lot of people
that he had worked with he just worked
in a regular
company with regular co-workers all of
his co-workers said
not only was he a completely normal
human being
but they had no idea that he was gay
they're like they just had no idea he
seemed completely straight
um it had never occurred to them he even
lived with a boyfriend
but he kept it a secret and so all of
his co-workers thought it was really
strange like when they found out about
it
he might have been bisexual too but i'm
just you know i'm not really sure
but he did have a boyfriend at home and
uh you know nobody
knew about it because he was like
keeping it secret so
um this guy answered the ad
um he was apparently he kind of had an
unhappy childhood
as well and he had a fantasy
about uh being killed and eaten
which like i said that's a thing
i suppose or is your drink empty almost
i got it no okay why are you looking to
take a break
um i was well because i kind of lost my
place in the notes so i was like looking
for
looking for where it was oh here we go
here we go here we go i got it
so what ends up happening is that
oh thank you very much joe oh thanks i
didn't even see that i didn't see that
uh oh okay they would also like you want
a shirt
are you gonna write that down all right
joe um contact jenny on facebook we'll
get your information or instagram
or instagram yeah what what model you
want
what size you want the size you want
your address we'll get all that and i'll
send you one out
yeah maybe it'll probably be a week or
so
yeah because i might have to order the
blanks depending on what size what size
yeah it is we have some in stock
other ones i'll have to order yeah
so uh so the two of them exchange a
bunch of emails
if i didn't mention the name of the site
before it's cannibal cafe i don't know
if it's still there or not
it was like a you know site where people
would post
you know fantasies about being eaten so
they decide they're gonna meet up on
march 9th
2001. burned takes a train
to rotenberg where uh armin
mives lives now
when burn gets there apparently without
too much preamble now
armin's mom has died in the interim like
she died in 1999 so
she's not in the house while this is
going on so i guess what ended up
happening was that
i mean he'd had cannibal fantasies since
he was a kid
but um once she died i guess
you know the training wheels came off i
suppose and he was just like okay well
it's time to crack down and
do this [ __ ] in real life and eat a
[ __ ] i guess
i mean you know so i guess she was the
only one keeping him from
acting on the [ __ ] and when she was gone
he just went hog wild
so apparently without any preamble they
bring
he brings uh you know burn to the house
and then they where are you going
take a break oh okay i was like well if
if i'd known that i'd put a commercial
on all right
so they decide they're gonna cut off
burns penis and that they're both
gonna eat it right
so they cut it off
and then uh and then
armin cuts it in half so they can each
have a piece but they're gonna eat it
raw though
so they both start to eat it
but it's not going too well because they
said it was too
chewy and so
armin says okay well i'll take them
downstairs to the kitchen
and cook the pieces and then maybe that
will make them better like
make them more edible so he took the
pieces down and put him in a pan and
started cooking them
but he ended up burning them which to me
like when i heard about that i was kind
of i know this is kind of like kind of a
messed up thing to think
but i was like if you had spent your
whole entire life
for example fantasizing about being
cannibalized like parts of your body
being cannibalized
and then you finally like got in your
head's like okay i'm gonna do it like
this is this is my year i'm gonna get
cannibalized this year like i don't know
how excited they get about it
so so they decide to do it and then you
get to the dude's house
you get it all done he cuts the dick off
and you're all excited about eating it
and then he [ __ ] burns the [ __ ]
i mean i don't know i just to me that i
know that's
messed up and that's probably just like
my [ __ ] up imagination talking but
it's like
man think about that guy's gonna be so
mad because now he's not going to be
able to do it again this is like a once
in a lifetime
uh situation so the fact that he burned
the penis
must have been like a big bummer
i'm just saying so he did burn it so
they couldn't really eat it
now i should note that armin because of
course he was
was recording this whole
uh occurrence
i think the video is like four hours
long some of it they showed at his trial
but they i think they only
showed like 20 minutes of it because it
apparently was just like too upsetting
for people and i'm sure
i'm not saying go look for it but i'm
sure it's [ __ ] somewhere on the
internet because everything is
um and the more horrible the better oh
there you are if you need to take a
break you can do the commercial break
no i'm all right um i just didn't know
you didn't say anything and you just
kind of wandered off
i didn't want to disturb you okay
yeah so no i was saying that like when
they when they he cut the dude's penis
off
and then he cut it in half so they could
both have some
and then they both ate it well no they
tried to but they tried to eat it raw
and it was too chewy
yeah so then armin says well i'll take
it downstairs and cook it
and then he burned it oh [ __ ] and then i
said i was saying
to them i was like um can you imagine
like this being your one big shot of
like
like being cannibalized and eaten and
the dude burned it he'd be like
maybe he laughed it off i don't know
but yeah weird [ __ ] he's like yeah it's
all right i won't be needing that
no but i'm just saying if you're going
to be eating this is there's only one
time that you're going to get eaten
you're going to
get to eat pieces he wasn't watching
enough he didn't had to cook he wasn't
watching it he's been fantasizing about
this [ __ ]
you would think he'd all this time he'd
be you think he'd be practicing
i can't believe it
you think he'd have he'd think he'd have
it all [ __ ] worked out what spices
and everything what cooking
you know karen mead says cajun style
okay [ __ ] blackened cajun dick
and they burned it too bad i mean it
could it wasn't going to taste good
anyway i mean
it's just it's a weed it's not gonna
taste good yeah it's just gonna be like
gristle
it's gonna be something that on a pig
you'd throw away i mean so what would
you wanna eat that for
you would think if you were really like
head up about like eating part of
yourself you said like yeah take it
take your leg off take like or or take
like part of your ass or something like
that
nice and fatty you think they're afraid
nice and well
marbled but you could take but he was
gonna die anyway you can take a leg off
you know
under the knee because you could put a
tourniquet like above the knee you know
cut it off
actually you could cut it off right
above the knee joint
put the tourniquet on the thing is
though is that all the pain and [ __ ]
would you be able to even eat it or
would you be going ah
you think that [ __ ] would hurt like
[ __ ] well according to the video
which i have not seen because i'm not
gonna watch that [ __ ] come on
yeah he videotaped the whole four hour
ordeal or whatever it was
so yeah so he tries to when he when he
cooked it he tried to like put stuff on
it like garlic and salt and pepper and
stuff
but he burned it too much and then like
he ended up cutting it up and feeding it
to the dog
oh [ __ ]
do you see my face what'd the dude say
do you see my face i don't know well
because the thing about it is that
they think according to the video it
seemed like
by the time like when he cut the penis
off
that he was already that burned was
already like
kind of weak from blood loss yeah so he
didn't really give much of a [ __ ] about
it
he didn't really try to eat it already
he didn't even try to eat it yeah yeah
now he ended up taking like he drunk a
bunch and he took like some sleeping
pills and stuff like that so he wasn't
real
um real aware what was that where yeah
he was kind of woozy
is what we're saying and then he was
like you know that's a [ __ ] sad
sack
he's a sad sack dude so his fantasy was
to be eaten
and to eat and alive but yet he [ __ ]
knocks himself out so he doesn't even
experience it
yeah that's kind of a [ __ ] cheap way
out
[ __ ] are crazy look thinking
about it's frustrating me but then
you never know what's going on the thing
that kills me about burned though
is that he was everybody that knew him
had no idea that he was even considering
this they said he was completely
normal and this is just goes to show
that he wasn't known
no but i mean he seemed normal like he
didn't like give any
off any red flags or anything so that's
what i'm saying it's like it's really
really creepy
to think that you could be like working
with somebody or like you know
some sales lady could be helping you at
[ __ ] dillards or something like that
and she could be going home later and
being like
um i'm gonna eat part of myself you know
what i mean it's like that's [ __ ]
crazy to me
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy to me
here we go again cannibals and recipes
my boy santa to bodine zan what's up bro
yeah we're all getting hungry yeah so
apparently
um after biting after uh the
penis eating didn't work um
apparently armin then tried to like
bite through uh
she ran i thought she had a lizard or
something oh my goodness you damn hair
rubber band she loves like those little
black like
ponytail holders and it's she gets like
super excited she treats them as if
they're alive
yeah she shows them to me you're like
look look i couldn't look they got it
yeah and she carries it like a one with
like one little finger and like flings
it and then
rolls around it's so [ __ ] funny i
have a whole bunch of them saying
i think about this [ __ ] and i'm like
this dude's going through all this
problem to be eaten by this dude but
then he takes all this dope so he's not
awake for when it happens
that's what he's just a huge letdown
yeah and the first thing he eats is dick
so you can't he can't like jerk it or
anything while he's eating a leg or
anything
so what the [ __ ] is this for that's what
i mean this is like something this is
like some [ __ ]
if you're only going to do it one time
yeah you better have this really really
careful
yeah victor garcia says is this going in
the cookbook no this is not going in how
to cook a penis no
okay how to cook a pizza oh wait xanada
asked what i
what i was drinking this is a it's a
vodka
sun sunset savanka sunset it's vodka
orange juice and yeah grenadine and i
got silver
tequila it's cuervo cuervo silva
with uh rockstar that's it
yeah um so how to cook a penis okay how
i would probably do it
is i'd probably [ __ ] um [ __ ]
uh batter it and deep fry it and then
[ __ ] well everything and then i'd
[ __ ] turn
i'd do it buffalo you know buffalo [ __ ]
you know what i mean deep fried like a
[ __ ] piece of buffalo chicken
like a buffalo chicken some blue cheese
blue cheese yeah blue cheese that's how
i do it it'd be gristly
with a lot of sinew and [ __ ] tendon
it would taste like [ __ ]
you'd be mostly tasting the [ __ ]
sauce
the sauce and the batter but that's how
you would do it
yeah now if you could get his nuts
involved in this [ __ ]
make sure them [ __ ] make sure their
[ __ ] are shorn freshly shorn
you don't want to [ __ ] hair nothing
in that and [ __ ] batter and deep fry
those and they'd be just like [ __ ]
oysters
mountain oysters yeah yeah up and
serving with [ __ ] lemon butter
all right it's lemon butter yeah
tempting
[Laughter]
but the dick you'd have to [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] buffalo style
yeah why would that i don't know it's
like i would be the worst thing you
could eat
well there's nothing edible on that
that's something that would be turned
into sausage or thrown away
yeah you think did you like grind that
up make it into a hot dog or something
it would probably
yeah it it may not most of that deck
wouldn't survive the centrifuging
process when you spin it to get rid of
all the trash
you're just trying to get the meat right
yeah most of that dick would end up
getting thrown out by the centrifuge
in other words what i'm saying what i'm
saying gentlemen is that your [ __ ] is
[ __ ] worthless
well especially for eating yeah when it
comes to food your cock's [ __ ]
worried nobody wants to eat
just don't tell a fat girl that though
just kick back and [ __ ] enjoy
oh man bad girl loves a blow
oh god all right so uh
so after the whole penis debacle
apparently this evening has not been
going the way either of them want it to
go
so what ends up happening then is that
like i said basically
burned is bleeding to death
and has drunk a bunch and taken a bunch
of sleeping pills
so he basically just goes upstairs and
lays in the bathtub
and pretty much just lays there and
allows himself to bleed to death
while armin stays downstairs reading a
star trek book
took burned three hours to bleed to
death
damn well he was reading the book huh
and then armin was down i mean i guess
this was agreed upon
i suppose yeah i don't really know what
was going on
like i said i haven't seen the video um
like i said he made a video of the whole
entire
encounter which was i think it was four
hours long yeah
um and i don't know if it's available
online i'm sure it probably is
they only showed about 20 minutes of it
to the jury
like at the trial because they thought
it was like just too [ __ ] gross for
people to look at
so so yeah it took three hours for the
guy to bleed to death while armin was
downstairs
reading a book and then he goes upstairs
to check on him
apparently he just kisses him one time
and then
slit his throat he was already dead
though right um
i don't think he was now okay he was
just he was unconscious though
as far as i know so he stabs him in the
throat and kills him
then he hangs the body on a meat hook
and um takes a bunch of uh flesh off of
it
like you would and uh he even took all
the bones and like ground him down and
made flour out of them
so you know waste not want not bone
flour
yeah that's just that's just contaminant
yeah why would you
he's trying to use all right he's trying
to be like environmentally
yeah responsible or something i don't
know
i just cook it down and make broth out
of it well that's what you're supposed
to do with bones
yeah i mean the picture says that's keto
it is
so so
he so he took all the meat and he stored
it
and he basically ate off it for like the
next 10 months i think he ended up
eating like 44 pounds of the dude
right yeah so
he would have gotten away with it if it
wasn't for those meddling kids
as they sound scooby-doo he might have
gotten away with it i'm not really sure
because no one really caught him or did
anything about it
um until
armin put up another ad
right he put up another ad saying he ate
one honestly
i don't know if he said that he had
eaten a person already like hey i
already did that [ __ ] so i'm totally
serious about it but he put up another
ad like looking for another victim yeah
and somebody saw it
and um you know maybe he did like
maybe that's why because i feel like
nobody reported the first ad because
everybody'd be like yeah whatever
but so he must have said something about
hey like look i i
said something he had experience i
cooked and ate this guy or something
like that so somebody that
you know set off some alarm bells so uh
somebody knarked on him like uh for the
ad
so the uh and i don't i don't think he
was terribly hard to find
or anything even though he wasn't going
by his real name but you know
you can find people's names easily so uh
so the uh investigators go to his
mansion
and uh they found the videotape
of the killing so you know and they
found
a whole bunch of body parts that he had
not eaten yet
so he goes to trial they were 10 months
old
yeah i guess they were frozen still you
know so it's free you're not supposed to
keep something 10 months in the freezer
you can but it i mean all right freezer
burn
feet i don't know it's a weird [ __ ]
it's so messed up so he goes to trial
now in uh january of 2004
he got convicted of manslaughter
and he was sentenced to eight and a half
years light sentence
it was but i think at the first trial
um they were kind of like well
the consent issue they were like look
this guy like willingly
came and said you know they're they're
like they're still like it's still
murder it's still not good
but it's not like he just grabbed a dude
off the street that didn't want to get
murdered this was a guy that actually
came there for
a purpose in the united states that
[ __ ] would have gotten life
well yeah now the thing
was though that there was a lot of
controversy about the case for that very
reason because he only got eight and a
half years for manslaughter
so there was a huge amount of media
attention and there was like a huge
argument about
well you know how far does consent go
it's like can you consent to be
eaten and cannibalized and is that still
not murder or is it like a lesser type
of murder
so there was like a big debate about it
the situation is this
if a guy can give consent about being
cannibalized then a guy could give
consent about being shot
which means that that would legalize
dueling again they wouldn't do it
yeah they would they can't that's what i
mean it's just because you take one
thing away and then it opens up
other things yeah personally i don't
believe you should be [ __ ] able to
eat somebody even if they want to be
eating
no but on the other hand i believe in
dueling
i think dueling would solve a lot of
problems if it was regulated properly
yeah instead of having people just doing
drive-bys and shooting each other you
know
in [ __ ] nightclubs or whatever just
have a legalized system where you can go
that's it [ __ ] i challenge you to a
[ __ ] duel
and if you don't [ __ ] accept a duel
then i win
you know what i mean and if he accepts a
duel then you go [ __ ] duel
because you've agreed to personal combat
yeah between an enemy if a state
can agree to combat against another
state
then why can't an individual willingly
enter into [ __ ] a state of warfare
with another individual who's agreed
upon it
i mean the thing is you could do that um
but like anything else you'd have to
have like a protocol yeah surrounding it
like you'd have to have like designated
dueling
areas areas yeah well they had all that
and you'd have to go through a certain
process
they'd had all that like to do it yeah
lawyers had to be there and everything
in the united states that's the way it
was done you can't just do it like
[ __ ] no not on the spot
willy-nilly you gotta go through the
[ __ ] you gotta go through the whole
thing
and it was ritualized and they're like
you had to choose weapons
lawyers had to be there you know and
that was so
it was a legal act it was legal warfare
between two individuals
yeah and i believe people have the right
to wage war on other individuals as long
as it's like i said
legal the other one wants to do it too
if they just can't live on the face of
the [ __ ] planet with each other
anymore
that situation [ __ ] exists sometimes
and until somebody can get sent to the
moon
[Laughter]
and it would solve a lot of political
problems there's some [ __ ]
that's it i can't stand to have you in
the senate
i challenge you to a duel i wage war on
you and if you don't [ __ ] accept it
then you're a [ __ ]
you know they used to do it back then
yeah you had [ __ ] presidents [ __ ]
was it jackson
was in a duel i think he was he's in a
couple of duels yeah and i think guys in
the senate every now and then dueled
and they sorted [ __ ] out you sort that
[ __ ] out
and if you don't sort it out then the
other guy's dead so win-win yeah well
it was mostly it was mostly a thing of
honor
yeah i mean dude didn't accept it then
you know his his word wasn't worth [ __ ]
you knew he was lying he didn't
he wasn't willing to fight about it yeah
so he pushed out
karen asked how about cannibalism for
survival like the donner party
or the chili yeah we said it before i
don't think yeah see i don't um
i don't have a problem with that um as
long as you're not like murdering people
but
if you're in a plane crash and there's a
bunch of dead people laying around um
and you need to eat meat to survive then
i don't have any problem with that at
all
yeah i mean you're just that person's
dead they're not using their meat
anymore
if you're in the wild and your party
members are dropping like flies from
[ __ ]
in the united states mostly cannibalism
was due to cold weather
yeah like the donner party yeah you're
just snowing
and you're frozen in there's nothing to
eat you're trying to get somewhere to
safety
people are dying dying of [ __ ]
exposure and hypothermia along the way
everyone is hungry there's no food they
ate them
to survive and the person who died was
also a survivor they would have totally
like approved it
and maybe they had just done it a few
days before you don't know
yeah but i mean because when you're in a
situation like that it'd probably be
like look if i die you can eat me it's
fine yeah i feel bad
and you know i think i think hardcore
mountain men
and hardcore survivors in the [ __ ]
old west here in the united states
you know because we have some foreign
foreign viewers
a good movie i'd recommend was called
jeremiah johnson
it was uh uh john millius the same guy
who did conan one
watched that movie robert redford was in
it and
there was a whole subculture of [ __ ]
dudes
trying to survive in the old united
states
along with the indians and they kind of
back in the day they'd accuse him of
going
indian which was just being too wild
and and in the movie it doesn't show it
but
jeremiah johnson was also known as liver
eaton johnson he was a cannibal
but it was more like ritual cannibalism
he was ken he was eating crow indians
he was eating their livers
because that's how you gain their
strength he was doing it
for revenge a lot of times rumored that
the crow had killed his
wife and his wife was a flathead indian
so
he evidently had a [ __ ] bad vendetta
against the crow
a lot of jeremiah was legend though we
don't really know much about jeremiah he
was an army scout evidently and was in
the navy
evidently he killed a [ __ ] with
another [ __ ] which
that's a bad [ __ ] to do
he cut he escaped from the crow
and killed a crow indian and cut that
crow's leg off
and killed another crow with that leg
yeah and then that leg when it froze
he was gnawing on it to try to get back
home he walked over 100 and something
miles just in a
few in a week a few weeks trying to live
so
jeremiah johnson look into him he was a
an american cannibal but also a legend
a legend yeah what's that somebody said
up there just don't eat the brain
yeah don't do that you'll get the kuru
yeah don't want to get that it's like
mad cow but
i mean it's the same thing so you know
uh except with humans
and then alex ramirez says do you mean
they ate each other up like
danny from the shining yep um
oracle says have you all reviewed the
movie ravenous not yet but it is on my
list because i love
love love that movie i actually saw that
in the theater
when it first came out and i've seen it
a bunch of times since then
it's also a cannibalism movie um yeah
so another thing too speaking of
cannibalism that was kind of
complicating things in the arm and myvis
trial was that
cannibalism was technically not illegal
in germany at the time i don't know it
was because they just didn't think of it
or they just didn't think there had to
be a law against it or
whatever but it wasn't illegal so
there was kind of like a human cry about
that now
armin maivis for his part he has come
out
and said that um you know he was
completely
uh open about what he did um he says
that he
regrets doing it he wants to write a
biography
about what he did so that other people
with the same fetish
don't do it because apparently it wasn't
a good experience to him he is also
now a vegetarian which i thought was
very funny
in a [ __ ] up kind of way so in
april of 2005 the german courts actually
decided they were gonna have a retrial
because there was all of this debate
about that he should have been
tried for murder instead of manslaughter
so so the prosecutors had appealed uh
the sentence and he they wanted him to
get life so
they so he got a retrial so one of the
uh issues was that even though
you know they they weren't they really
only had
you know the emails and stuff like that
like saying you know did bernd
really consent to the killing did he
really know what he was getting into so
there was that issue
um he had mental problems you know he
was
drunk he was on sleeping pills at the
time so it's like could he really give
consent
um and they were also saying that
had um armin mives killed him
for sexual pleasure which
would lean more toward a murder uh
you know conviction rather than a
manslaughter conviction you know what
i'm saying
so they had psychologists in there
and uh talking about armin's fantasies
and that it
definitely was like a sexual thing
uh eating the guy killing him and
everything so
he gets this on the second trial which
ended in may of 2006 they actually
did end up convicting him of murder and
sentenced him to life
in prison well they realized that muffin
was too dangerous to just let him walk
around
yeah even though i mean like i said he
said he doesn't want to do it anymore
and he doesn't even
eat meat anymore um but
i don't know that seems like somebody
you might not
trust that dude walking around i mean
once you've gone that far you know what
i'm saying
um i wouldn't trust that dude yeah so
i'm
just kind of like i have to say that was
probably the best uh
decision even if he never did it again
it's still
you like you said you can't trust him no
so his judgment is [ __ ] way [ __ ]
yeah you can't happen now so while he's
in prison
um he does actually seem to be trying to
uh help out in other cannibalism cases
or other similar cases like you know in
psychological profiling and stuff
so he is actually seems to be making
some kind of contribution which i
suppose is good
um but you know so this case
obviously very very famous not only in
germany but around the world
uh so there have been like a ton of
[ __ ] movies about a plays about it
uh romstein did a song about it
[Laughter]
called mind tile i guess uh my dick my
penis whatever
i think is what that means i'm not
really sure we have a couple of germans
in there
but yeah so uh marilyn manson uh
had an album called eat me drink me
which was uh partially inspired
by uh by him there was also a movie
called butterfly a grim
love story uh which was about this which
i kind of want to see now i haven't
actually seen that
but uh that sounds pretty good but
there's been like a ton of other ones
like other
kind of [ __ ] about this because this was
like a huge
deal because i think this is really the
first time
that a widely publicized case like this
of someone that actually killed and ate
somebody that
said that they wanted to be killed and
eaten yeah so it's kind of like a
fascinating
uh thought experiment i guess just still
like
it's storming out there here it really
is yeah we might need to warn them we
might lose internet if we yeah so if we
go off it's okay we didn't get like
killed and eaten by
anyone we just did you want to get a
commercial break in
yeah i might do a commercial break now
because that was pretty much the end of
that
okay we're gonna puke on the and uh yeah
i got
i got commercials i got a couple kitty
videos
and stuff like that and uh then when we
come back we will talk about
sharon lopotka who was another woman who
for some reason wanted to be tortured
and killed not eaten
i guess the guy didn't eat her but it
was kind of a similar thing
all right so i'm going to run a couple
kitty videos and a couple commercials
you got to make a new drink and then
we'll be back in just
a couple minutes
so um look how we found pookies
what you doing polk yeah
did something bad happen she had none of
the rights it's
a genius disguise i mean i never
recognized no i wouldn't have ever even
seen you
[Laughter]
why are you it weird can you tell me
you don't know yeah she's like what i
don't
okay
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing
unsolved murders of the 20th century
it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the ketty
murders the carrie babies case the frog
boys
the alcasar murders and the anoka shira
park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999.
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
just want to swim through the envelopes
yeah
what's up hey
yeah are you gonna try and crawl
underneath
what's up what's up
oh you just
please don't eat that
could i please ask you not to eat the
envelopes
please i know how much you love to eat
paper what's up little one
where are we going look
huh yeah check that [ __ ] out
check that [ __ ] out well now you closed
it
i had it open so you could jump inside
you're not having it okay bye join us
september 25th
26th and 27th for a three-day special
streaming event
strange realities to push the limits of
your
reality featuring authors academics
researchers occultists experiencers
podcasters and practitioners
all presenting fresh cutting-edge
material and research
streaming live featuring presentations
by brett reagan editor of alternate
perceptions magazine aaron gulias host
of the saucer live podcast david metcalf
fighter
and researcher alan greenfielder of
secret cipher of the euphemism
stephanie quick item and blogger red
pill junkie 14 researcher and explorer
tim bernal host of banal of america guy
malone class
troublemaker timothy ritter host of
strange familiars
dombrowski author and practitioner greg
bishop author of
project theta jenny ashford host of 13
o'clock
recluse taste of the farm jack
montgomery folk magic
joshua these in the ninth reverend
michael carter
alien contact experiencer dr future host
of feature club tony kale author of
memphis hoodoo
and ryan collier occultist soraya askow
host of word of the world
john tinney ghost stalkers and help all
three days only 20
tickets and info available at strange
realitiesconference.com
brought to you by the conspira normal
podcast spiritnormal.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hold on oh my god
holy crap this is getting it was
it was really really bad last night
though we didn't lose power so i'm kind
of hoping
it's lightning out there lightning and
[ __ ] storm and hopefully we won't
lose our connection
yeah i mean you know at least we got
i like how you make that manly man
that's the manly [ __ ] man man
i do that [ __ ] [ __ ] throws the door
and she throws it wide open bam she hits
the door and walks in
like she's walking into a [ __ ] saloon
i know why is this closed
yeah she's so small but she's like very
forceful
she has a lot of strength in her little
arms [ __ ] smacking the door open and
looking around like how dare you shut
that
i will not be ignored yeah that's pretty
definitely so we're coming up on the
second hour
yeah was that the second hour or just i
don't know what what time or what time
were we at let's see
i'm not really sure because i'm not i
don't have a counter i'm not in the same
uh
window so i'm not really i'll show you
the counter there oh well i guess we'll
just have to use our imagination
yeah we're just sitting there playing
with it well i guess we've started well
i guess we've been on for
we started at five and it's 6 30. okay
so we've been going for
an hour making pretty good time actually
so that's pretty probably a three hour
show tonight
yeah oh my god it's crazy outside right
now you guys don't even know oh man
oh [ __ ]
i'll tell you what man cuervo silver
has a [ __ ] really weird taste to it
that i haven't really gotten
uh it's that silver it's actually not
silver it's cuervo especially
silver it's special it's special and it
has
look like that oh you hear that
[ __ ] just use that enough i know i said
yeah i thought the sprinklers turned on
or something i was like what the hell
okay poltergeist attack
but corvo special kind of tastes like
they say you know it's got that blue
agave
yeah [ __ ] man there's too much of that
blue agave it tastes kind of like
[ __ ]
soap see cactus soap
or something cactus soap yeah there's a
lot there's a lot of better flavors that
that sam's
silver tequila is the [ __ ] best i've
been able to find the closest thing
to it would be uh milagro silver
which is weird i wonder who makes all of
the
all the sam's brand stuff it's deluxe
whatever because all their stuff is
really good
all their shit's good like all of their
vodka like the big huge thing about
like the the bottle that big is like
13.99
yeah and that tastes like gray goose
yeah it's just like i don't have any
like i sometimes i buy skye if we don't
feel like driving all the way to sam's
i asked j i asked jair i said jair
what's the best what's the best tequila
in in tijuana because he lives in
tijuana in case you guys don't know he's
listener
and he goes oh man milagro and he goes
you go to the [ __ ] hotels or any of
the
he works at a hotel and you go to any
hotel or any bar
man [ __ ] top shelf over there for you
know we're not talking about
we're not talking about you know custom
[ __ ] craft tequilas you know we're
just talking about a
corporate tequila you know it says
malagro malagro that's the top shell
yeah i can't tell the difference between
sam
silver and [ __ ] malagra silver it
tastes the same to me well like i said i
can't tell the difference between the
sam's vodka
and skye or gray goose or any other
brand that i get yeah it's not cheap
it's good [ __ ] i mean like i said
because the publix liquor store is like
a lot
closer so it's like if i really don't
feel like driving because i
we really only go to sam's if we need a
bunch of stuff because i don't want to
drive all the way out there unless we
need
like you know [ __ ] you need in bulk and
then we'll get like the cheap liquor but
if we just need liquor i just go to the
public store
so i get skye and i think that's 20
bucks
uh for the same size bottle as the one
you get at sam's for like 13 or 14
dollars and honestly i can't tell the
difference between the two
so there you go but uh everybody uh
everybody's thanking us for doing the
starting times of the shows that it
works out good for europe
it works out good for us too because i
mean when you have an evening after week
yeah i mean it's fine after we get off
work even though
even though by the time we're done with
the show we're pretty hammered and it's
like
usually i just put like gordon ramsay or
like unsolved mysteries on or something
that i
fall asleep i fall asleep i think i fell
asleep at like 9 30 last year
florida florida's still locked up
there's really god damn listen that's it
i know it's crazy
it's like atmosphere florida's still
locked up so there's no clubs there's
nowhere to go
and i imagine you guys are probably
locked up too yeah we can't really go
anywhere i mean
like i said not like we went a hell of a
lot of places before
yeah but we used to go out every
saturday yeah well the thing was is like
that last six months or so before this
[ __ ] happened
uh for some reason i just feel like i
want to go out we had so much [ __ ] we
had to do
yeah so it's like we hadn't even really
been going out much before like
the rona even came along
so this is just kind of taking a break
so this is kind of like
not i mean it sucks but it's not really
that different
yeah i'm ready to go back out though
yeah
aren't you yeah i mean we did go to uh
we went to mannequins yeah a while back
yeah that was before they shut down
again again right yeah i'm just hoping
this shit's [ __ ] go over getting over
with
if you leave it up to these
[ __ ] they'll never open back up
you just they gotta be forced to open up
they'll open up
ron desantis will open up florida at
least eventually
yeah adam said thanks for playing the
strange realities ad
you're very welcome i'll i'll try to
show i'll try to play it
yeah if you guys got any ideas or any
suggestions what you want for [ __ ]
commercial breaks or music or whatever
just i can put it in the comments i need
some more pookie videos yeah
those are just the two most recent ones
that i had yeah another thing is is that
uh your comments
in the comments section i do see them
don't you know don't be offended if i
don't respond because
i see your comments just i can't
interrupt jenny we got to get the show
rolling so i can't i can't respond to
every comment in there but i do see it i
do appreciate i do appreciate what you
guys are saying holy crap
i am kenneth says that uh he has a story
for me
about a fellow christian school student
killed her mother
happened in pennsylvania yeah tell me
about that [ __ ]
like just message me on instagram or
facebook and tell me about it
uh he also asked where's the pole in the
disco ball we haven't got that
yeah yeah one of these although i tell
you what i did order i don't i ordered
the onions you got the on air so i got
the honey we can put it over there let's
put it over there in front of in front
of it it'll be over here above
jenny's head over here yeah when you're
looking to be over here but against that
wall
like somebody said earlier it's like
wkrp in cincinnati yeah if anybody's old
enough to remember it's fully
programmable and it's got bluetooth and
everything so you can change the
the colors of the words and i'll have
patterns in there it'll match it'll look
good
for a while i had on my mac i had a
weird screensaver going but i guess it
went on will look like a radio show
yeah and we'll pretend that we're
transmitting radio
which is feeble compared to internet but
you know what i mean
we did radio shows before we've done we
did one of the biggest radio shows in la
and it made no impact what was that one
radio show that we did
with with with with steve yeah that was
that was one of the weirdest experiences
doing live radio i've ever had hey i'm
from
uh from i felt like the dudes there was
like three or four hosts
yeah and i felt like one idiots they
were all idiots well i felt like they
were all
super high yeah and it's like they
weren't even they had us on but it's
like then they were like talking about
football and they were like just talking
among themselves like we weren't even
there
and it was like the weirdest thing ever
yep i was just kind of like why are we
even like i was just kind of sitting
there talking so i moved away man i was
you know
it was hilarious i was born in
california moved away like in
81 or 82 and it's just a very
i just felt like they were definitely
super super super high dumb
california is dumb it was just three or
four high people and then i
feel like they just forgot we were on
the road
everybody's leaving there's a mass
exodus from there even joe rogan said
he's leaving
he says everybody's [ __ ] leaving
there's just it's just not worth it to
stay there it's overpopulated
either the quality of living is bad it
was bad when i was there
i don't know how they [ __ ] take it
and they just they want to attack some
fifty percent of [ __ ]
they're leaving they're leaving
okay people bitching about [ __ ]
florida in the area that we're in now
this is the way california was when i
was a little kid it's like this i
[ __ ] loved it
it was like this is like california back
in the 70s i hate florida because it's
like satan's ass crack like
it's just so [ __ ] we don't have any
winter we don't we don't have any
seasons
there are no seasons no it's hot and
it's not
depressing that's it well hot and less
hot yeah as i say hot and less hot it's
just basically like
swamp ass 365 100 humidity
most of the time yeah i mean like i said
i've been
i've been going out for walks earlier
like in the summer i go like as soon as
the sun goes up like comes up like at 6
30 like i go out
and it's still [ __ ] hot it's like
dagobah
but what's good about it is trouble that
heat humidity will keep all those
california's away from here
so when they flee california they'll go
to texas and stop there
they won't come in because it's deserty
still because as desert is drier and
they have to worry about the humidity
californians can't have yeah because
heat and humidity that's two different
things
two different things i love heat i don't
oh man [ __ ] you should have
the sinai desert in egypt when i was
there for that i mean i've been to
desert it's [ __ ] great
and it's better but it's like i still
don't i don't like being hot
at all it'd be 110 degrees but zero zero
percent humidity and it was just
totally like [ __ ] fine i like it
being like a little bit
chilly so that like not so you're
freezing your balls off but
just so it's cold enough that you need
kind of like a sweater and a scarf
if it was like that all the time then
that would be safe yeah we're gonna get
hit by a lightning bolt
probably maybe we should get into the
second case in case we get cut off or
something
yeah well like i said everyone said
we're warning everybody right now
because it's like storming outside
we might lose this transmission
[Laughter]
we might lose the transmission i lose
this transmission yeah
so this case here this was a case that
i had not heard of until i started
looking into
like consensual murder and cannibalism
cases this was pretty much the only
other major one that
comes up when you put in like consensual
murder other than the armenis case
now this is the case of sharon lopatka
so this woman uh she was also born in
1961 weirdly so she was like the same
age
uh as armin maivus was
now she was originally from hampstead
maryland and she was the oldest of uh
four daughters
she was born to orthodox jewish parents
now she gets raised in baltimore um
everybody that they talk to like people
that she went to school with and stuff
like that just like in the case of like
uh the victim and the arm and myvis case
said she was completely and
totally normal she was on sports teams
she was in the school choir totally
normal
nothing stood out whatsoever
so she graduates in 1979
um and she married a construction worker
named
uh victor in 1991.
so then they moved to this house in
hampstead maryland in the early 1990s
so i guess she married like pretty young
and i guess she was just trying to get
away from her parents maybe her parents
were really strict or something like
that so
like a lot of girls do that grow up in
like strict households they kind of like
just marry the first dude that comes
along
uh just to get the [ __ ] out of the house
so it seems that that's probably what
she did and her parents were
apparently not happy about it so in 1995
um sharon's kind of ahead of her time
she starts doing
uh online advertising businesses she's
running
like all of these simultaneous like
online businesses and like i said this
is 1995 this is like early
yeah early internet very early internet
so i think we had only just
gotten dial up in 1995 or maybe it was
96.
so i have a huge nostalgia for early
internet
just dude the way i look the way it
looked
the way it sounded the fact that you
were one of the few [ __ ] that
were on it
it was [ __ ] cool man i liked it and
billy idol even made an album about that
early internet called cyberpunk
remember that [ __ ] where he was
pretending like he was the only
[ __ ] on the internet
he was internet wouldn't really be much
fun if you were the only person who felt
like he was the only one on it
that was like 93. i think it was like 93
[ __ ] yeah yeah
he and he was talking like about how
great
the internet was and how hackers and
people could talk to each other going
coming underneath people's radar
and doing [ __ ] you know what i mean and
and he was on to something i thought he
was full of [ __ ]
at the time billy idol
the british elvis copy did for c the
power of the internet
he foresaw made a whole album about it
it was funny it was the concept funny
when you left that album came with a
[ __ ] floppy disk
did it really yes it did i have it i
didn't remember that
yeah i didn't know about it it was the
little hard ones
yeah you know what i mean and it was
just a stupid program look like old
internet you had his lyrics and pictures
and [ __ ]
uh a loop of that was like
yeah yeah and it came with it it came
with a cd with
the the cd music you know what i mean
with the cd came that little [ __ ]
disc and it was like [ __ ] futuristic
i wanted to really see it's like man
what the [ __ ] is on this disc i didn't
have a computer at the time
i was in the army one day i [ __ ]
finally [ __ ] got a computer that
played i put it in there and i went oh
that's it that's all it's on it took
forever for that [ __ ] to
load too that's how that was it was like
in the old days you couldn't
get the old days take forever when
you're trying to get porn and it's just
like one picture
line by line [ __ ] take like 10
minutes to get the picture and you're
going to everybody
next picture then like five hours later
[Laughter]
thank you very much that burger looks
pretty good elvis thanks for very much
it's a penis burger
i can't thank you with the authority of
elvis i can only thank you with the
authority of orion
yeah yeah holy crap when you hear that
voice that's not elvis that's orion it's
talking
yeah yeah i'm not high enough rank
[Laughter]
michael schaefer said you finished
before the picture downloaded exactly
yeah exactly exactly
you would think that if anybody well i
guess they didn't have the technology to
do this back then but you think at least
like the tits and the badge would load
like before the rest of the picture
because like they don't care what
they're facing i remember
i remember when the hottest thing on the
internet was [ __ ] danny ash remember
danny ash
yeah yeah yeah not daniel ash no it
wasn't rocky
it was one of the first slides of the
different person that was like one of
the first
cyber girls you know the main [ __ ]
she has i remember the name she had her
own
website [ __ ] howard stern with
[ __ ] newer would
promote her [ __ ] webs website [ __ ]
daddy's hard drive
and it was like [ __ ] way ahead of his
time she made millions hurt her husband
yeah she was cute she got a good-looking
kind of full-figured kind of bombshell
type
why did dudes why not do well not all
dudes but like why do some dudes want
women to call them daddy
i don't know who said that that's pretty
weird somebody else there's a lot of
like porn and [ __ ] like that you just
you just reminded me of that because you
said
well you said danny's hard driving
instead of like said daddy's hard drive
and i was like
then i was like what's with the daddy i
don't know i don't know that's really
weird
[Laughter]
it's a pip thing or it's a daddy issue
thing maybe
like maybe people want to like i think
pimps make their stable call them daddy
yeah yeah i don't know if i'd be down
with that or not that's
a little too creepy they're taking care
of them
they probably have daddy issues to begin
with that's what i'm saying they don't
have daddies they don't know who daddy
is so [ __ ] pimp becomes daddy
yeah so it's like if you do know who
your dad is you're like yeah no thank
you yeah right
if you don't know who your dad is and
then then maybe it's not that
[ __ ] becomes your daddy yeah all right i
guess it's a well
it's not okay i'm just saying it's more
understandable
so yeah so take a [ __ ] to vegas and
make all kinds of money
this is one of his favorite things that
he talks about i've been taking men to
vegas
he's whenever whenever somebody's like
[ __ ] with me
[ __ ] with him yeah he says that he's
gonna take them to vegas and put him in
his stable
of horse yeah
and i don't know because he's got one of
those apparently yeah i always
i always say that to men though
[Laughter]
the one that i was [ __ ] really really
[ __ ] going hard on was a
hard on about that was [ __ ] well
what's his name
um the dude that [ __ ] wouldn't leave
me alone
a little fat oh who [ __ ] idolized me
one one one he went to korea oh oh
what was that guy's name
chad yeah chad i think his name was chad
chad
c-h-e-d chad yeah didn't know how he
spelled it
remember how that [ __ ] was
always asking you what i would think
about what something he did
yeah that's some weird [ __ ] yeah what do
you think tom would think about this
what do you think tyler was saying like
i don't know ask him yeah he was scared
to ask me
because you've been like man [ __ ] off
yeah i was like
you keep [ __ ] standing too close to
me i'm gonna take your ass to [ __ ]
face
i'm gonna put you up my [ __ ] stables
i'm gonna make money off that he always
yeah and he's a little fat boy you know
the man [ __ ] and i turn him around
and i'd say look at that
[ __ ] you are literally sitting on a
[ __ ] goal not a gold mine
i'm gonna cash in on that [ __ ] me and
you are gonna become rich
okay he's like what what are you talking
about what are you talking about you're
standing too close to me one of these
days i'm gonna ask you for all that
money you're supposedly making from this
table
yeah there's that gold mine they've all
been sitting on where i had them
i had to make that up for the chad
though man
we were this is happening in nightclubs
and he's [ __ ]
i'm getting drunk and he's standing too
[ __ ] close to me
remember because yeah
is that a man has a space bubble
well everyone has a space bubble i don't
want people all up in my grill either
yeah
and and you know what i mean [ __ ]
when you're standing close to me like
that
i'm gonna start [ __ ] make certain
interpretations
okay and that's where all that [ __ ] came
from and really what it was is he was
trying to get it to rub off on him
you know what i mean because we were
[ __ ] looking good and this and that
he was trying to get a status boost
by being seen with us see wouldn't that
been funny if he had just walked up
without saying anything and just started
rubbing himself on you
i knocked that [ __ ] out and put him up
in front of me because you don't get
behind me you get in front
it's gonna be a battle between the tops
and the box
i don't [ __ ] play that so i'll put
that hoe in his [ __ ] place
consistently you have to [ __ ]
consistently
yeah because it's it's a law okay and
all laws of the universe are consistent
there is no violation it's like the
speed of light
let's feel it it's like the speed of
light it's like gravity it's [ __ ] like
that you know what i mean a
motherfucker's not gonna [ __ ] violate
the laws of the universe this is not
gonna happen
okay look you gotta get back
yeah so uh so yeah like i said this
sharon lady
way ahead of her time with the online
advertising
so she hosts a website the first one she
did was called
you know love this house of dion and she
was selling
home decor guides like through the mail
and they were seven dollars
so apparently what these were and i mean
i guess i made
i guess she made money doing this so
they were like these
magazine type guides that were like
telling you
like all this fancy interior decorating
[ __ ] that
they don't want you to know because yes
that's like catnip for people yeah
apparently you put that in your [ __ ]
ad and everybody's like oh i'm going to
click on that they don't want me to know
that
it's like if they didn't want you to
know that that [ __ ] wouldn't work it
wouldn't be there
that [ __ ] might have worked back in 95
though oh i'm sure it's
back in 95. it still works now they do
it they still do it i mean it's like
they think it works on old people i
don't know
yeah i don't think it's kind of like you
put the word liberty on anything and old
people will buy it
that's what i mean you name anything
like liberty anything
the heritage heritage liberty right
anything like that
yeah there's a whole [ __ ] list of
words
to use yeah like if you want to
yeah if you want to like separate old
people from them from their [ __ ]
money
that's you know it's terrible but
if it didn't work if it didn't work they
wouldn't do it this is the world we live
in that's all i'm saying
so yeah so apparently this first thing
you or you paid seven dollars and then
you would get this thing in the mail
that was like that gave you all these
decorator secrets
it's apparently stuff that interior
decorators know but they didn't want you
to know
i'm not sure what that could be but
there's a whole guild
of interior decorators holding on
they're like the freemasons man
they could tell you but they'd have to
kill you it's basically that's awesome
interior decorators it's not really
somebody i thought of having like a
secret interior decorators guild
it's like [ __ ] like a bunch of
[ __ ] ninjas you got [ __ ] steven
seagal back there ninja interior
decorators that's the next
uh that's the next asylum movie right
there
they can do ninja [ __ ] and decorate your
house at the same time
i know you think you know what primary
colors are and what goes along with what
but let me tell you something
don't [ __ ] with me
[Laughter]
i'm gonna tell you something right now
put the mirror on the wall it makes
it makes the room look larger yeah
[Laughter]
i'm gonna tell you something right now
you [ __ ] with my track lighting i'm
gonna break your [ __ ] neck
oh my god track lighting yeah you
remember that [ __ ] my daughter
my dad track lighting back in the day
back when you were a [ __ ] rich pimp
you put a track light over the top of
your [ __ ] ceiling
that's right i put the trash search
lights and [ __ ]
yeah i can light up my artwork yeah yeah
the artwork that i bought at [ __ ]
kirklands or whatever
oh my god
[Laughter]
if you don't watch out
he's gonna you are gonna be so shocked
when steven seagal shows up on our
doorstep one day
i'm gonna [ __ ] pull out my [ __ ]
camera i'm gonna take a picture of that
and i'm gonna go jenny jenna's here hold
the camera
i'll walk out to [ __ ] steven seagal's
big fat ass man
[ __ ] put me in the [ __ ] arm
[ __ ] twist lockers
he'll [ __ ] slam you thank you very
much bro
slam my ass to the ground like he did
[ __ ] what's his name luke lugusamo
john like what's up yeah who's like half
his size good one
beats up on little dudes i do assaulting
i feel like what i can do like in
preparation
okay next time we're at the store girl's
name is
sultana mia now is that is that a title
or is that a name
[Laughter]
i like it she's the sultana i like it
whatever princess
in fact i think that the queen i think
that you should call me that from now on
because i'm like the [ __ ] queen of
this [ __ ] okay yeah no i'm just saying
that next time we go to the store
yeah i'm going to buy a box of
ding-dongs
and so when steven seagal comes to the
door all you have to do is take one of
the ding-dongs and throw it
and then he will waddle after it yeah
and he will be gone and your problem
will be taken care of i don't know
so he won't even like sit on you or
anything i don't know
[ __ ] him works that way
well you know i'm not mean to most
people but it's just like people like
that i just can't
get back to the show jenny get back to
the show okay i will i'm gonna come and
kick tom's ass
not much of a threat but little
[ __ ]
little danzig [ __ ] yeah all his
little daughters he's got like 20
daughters i think all of them
does he's got a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of kids
all of them from different women
i mean i knew he had some but i didn't
know he had that yeah and i think
they're all like russian
daughters aren't they all like russians
didn't he give birth to a whole [ __ ]
did he order a bunch of wives no he
moved to russia
he was he was in eastern europe i mean
when you're when you're like that you
gotta run
you know he ran because he well he
didn't run literally
no because he he flew but he was he was
he's facing he's facing some charges i
think maybe roll a moon pie out the door
yeah yeah go get that yeah
saunders says what the heck is a ding
dong um it's kind of like
it's a ding dong it's like it's like a
chocolate cake it's like a cupcake but
it's like puck shaped like a hockey puck
yeah and it's chocolate and i think it's
got white
[ __ ] in the middle no yeah that's a
totally bad description of a digno
a ding-dong i'm thinking of a ring ding
the original okay those are two
different things the ding-dong is the
old name for it they
changed the name to king dawn
that's right okay but when we were
little kids it was called a ding dong
yeah also there's a ho ho which is yeah
which is kind of the same thing
yeah i think a kit a kit a ding-dong was
made by it was made by hostess wasn't it
maybe maybe yeah and it was a little bit
bigger than a hockey puck
so about that big around cylindrical
yeah
about that tall and it was a
piece of chocolate cake with white
creamy filling like out of a twinkie and
then the whole thing was
covered in chocolate yeah chocolate
glaze so it was chocolate
chocolate cake it was like chuck but it
wasn't like icing it's like it's like
that
fondant yeah [ __ ] on the outside yeah
and then like uh there's a pack of two
of them in a pack of king
ding dongs and yeah but when we were
kids you could get them for probably
about 35 cents
yeah uh then eventually they kind of
went up to like i don't know probably a
dollar
when then they ended up going up almost
to a dollar it wouldn't charge me if
they were right
that same company made all those [ __ ]
at turnovers like little pies
now see those that was right there those
were good
that was i like the whole the lemon one
i like the chocolate one with snoopy on
it
it was just like the pie crust and then
it was just like chocolate pudding
inside
and then they had and they were like
they were like as big as a [ __ ]
calzone
yeah a cherry cherry one they're all
good they all they're all
pretty they sell this anymore yeah they
probably don't because they went
bad quickly so you had to sell a lot of
them you you could probably find them
that's true the thing is is that the uh
they were much better heated up in a
microwave
well but we didn't know that it was
before microwaves when when i first
found them i was a little kid but
there he heat him up just for like 15
seconds laughing her ass off a ho ho
ho ho oh [ __ ] oh thank you
very much thank you so much stream looks
great thank you
we've been like working on it today
everybody's showing up i
i very quickly learned how to use obs so
i could like put some kind of oh i
forgot to put my
i forgot to put my little uh what you
call it my little ticker back yeah but
i forgot to dance yeah that's right see
them
i was scrolling down at it just like jay
learned how to do it in three
hours maybe intros and outros and
[ __ ] breaks and everything pretty
proud of myself
yeah i'm sure i'm still gonna [ __ ] it up
because like i said i was just scrolling
down through this
through the little scenes or whatever
and it started playing the intro for
some reason i didn't
take a break oh he's gonna go take a
break okay well i'm gonna talk some more
about this lately
okay yeah
we did yeah we did get um the we're
using the same webcam but i actually
have
uh the actual correct software for it
now
uh so i'm actually able to because
before we were streaming on a mac and
i guess this webcam didn't have any mac
compatible software
so i was just using like a second hand
like you know
another program and i guess it wasn't
really
maximized so it does look a lot better
and i'm very happy about it but yeah
just thought i had a stroke it was just
yeah i was just that's the thing it's
like this i just got this laptop
yesterday
and i'm not really used to the touchpad
yet because it's kind of different from
my mac one like the way it works so i
was just like scrolling up through the
scenes like trying to get back to my
ticker
and it for some reason started playing
the intro video
even though i didn't push on it so i
don't know we'll sort out all the bugs
like i said this is the first time that
i'm actually streaming with this program
i didn't even know it existed until like
six hours ago so you know
so this lady sharon lopotka
so she she had her little uh decorating
thing like her catalog that she sold
through the mail for seven dollars a
piece so she had that going
and then she had some websites for doing
psychic ratings because of course she
did
um she also had like um
some of those like pay numbers that they
used to have like back in the 90s that
was like very big where you could like
phone a psychic and
you know you could call pretty much you
[ __ ] man like back in the old days when
nightmare on elm street was a big thing
they had a pay number like a
1 900 number that you could call and
talk to freddie for [ __ ] sake so
it was a very big thing in the 90s i
don't know why and it was like three
dollars a minute
or like three dollars for the first five
minutes and then like 75 cents a minute
or something
so she like ran a bunch of those so
she also um had some porn going
like you do now the porn she was selling
under a different name
uh not her own name she was under the
name nancy carlson
now the porn that she was selling which
should give you a clue to how she ended
up
was that she was very into um
selling porn of women that had been
drugged hypnotized or chloroformed
uh having sex with one another so that
was kind of her fetish
so she was selling porn of that like in
the 90s
she also sold uh what she touted as her
own used panties
so had a bunch of ads saying hey who
wants to buy my used underwear
whether it was really hers or not
because she tried not
not to be um uncharitable but
she was not a super attractive woman
although i guess that doesn't really
matter because i've seen some porn with
some women that i'm just kind of like
okay and there's like you know they have
like millions of people like being like
ooh she's so hot i'm like all right
whatever hold on one second in the
stream right now
you'll see a user called khan of auslan
and that's my boy jair from
um tj from tijuana
he's my homeboy you know coming from the
la area
tijuana and [ __ ] southern california
they're right there in fact
in mexico they [ __ ] with people from
tijuana because they say they're too
much like americans
all right but uh he's helping help
helping me with the mexican section in
the cookbook
yeah they've been like doing all kind of
like live chat back and forth and live
videos and stuff
yeah about how to make tortillas and
stuff and [ __ ] we made we i made some
tortillas today made chicken we just got
the tortilla pressure the other day
good yeah so he's been like trying got
that [ __ ] tortilla press from mexico
cast iron [ __ ] it's nice
kanavasan saw that [ __ ] he goes oh
that's the good brand that's the good
brand how much was that it wasn't that
expensive
45 that's not bad yeah it was cast iron
though man
it's a good one and i'm getting a lot
better with it
but anyway he was the guy i was telling
you about
about the um when i asked him it says
you know what's the most popular
like top of chef tequila in um
in in in mexico and he he's like well
[ __ ] milagro
i was like what you know like it's the
same ones they have here
malagra i thought it was gonna be some
kind of craft [ __ ]
tequila you know yeah and the closest
thing i've been able to find
to milagro silver here in the united
states is [ __ ] is sam's
silver tequila it's [ __ ] exactly the
same thing for like
which what is one-third does that even
have a brand name
it just says sam silver tequila 100
agave [ __ ]
uh premium silver tequila okay it comes
in a fancy [ __ ] bottle but it's only
like
20 for that big old [ __ ] bottle
and it's one-third the price
of [ __ ] milagro silver and it tastes
the [ __ ] same to me
i think it is milagro silver it might be
they might try
this because i kind of i i don't know
how widespread this is nowadays i would
assume it's still pretty widespread
but i think that a lot of like real big
corporations
that make all these all this brand name
[ __ ] i think they have
they also do runs of other [ __ ] that you
can
put under different names and in
different packaging yeah you know what i
mean
like so i think there's a lot of that
going on so some of the [ __ ] that
is you know is maybe like off-brand
is probably the same [ __ ] it's coming
from the same distillery it's just in a
different
those distilleries you can place uh you
can place orders from them
and i think what they do is they go look
we want to get something kind of like
milagros silver
can you sell us something that is taste
just like that but it's a little bit
different so
you can't get sued and they probably
come up with something to a slight
variation
but if i could put milagro silver and
[ __ ]
sam's tequila silver side by side i
couldn't tell them apart
yeah it tastes the same and it's
one-third the price
yeah but i'm drinking this uh
[ __ ] jay here i'm drinking this
[ __ ] cuervo especially silver
man it took a while to get used to it
man it's like drinking soap
it's like a soap flavor man it's [ __ ]
weird
so yeah he's talking about bro
sandra says someone here who wants to
buy my underwear would be cool not to
have to do all that washing and even get
money for it right yeah just yeah
i thought the browner the better i get a
bonus
oh
you went there they're sick sick dudes
haven't like i've thought about like i
don't know if i would ever do it but
it's like it's kind of like i wonder if
anybody would want my underwear
like my old stinky shoes don't say that
you'll get dudes in the [ __ ] comment
sections i'll give you a 200 i'll give
you 300
i'll be like all right okay we'll send
this [ __ ] out i don't wear underwear
underwear
[Laughter]
i can tell you some sticky shoes though
if you're into if you have flip flops
[ __ ] the cats love that [ __ ]
they're trying to crawl inside the shoe
hooky loves my shoes
she has a foot fetish they go to the
boundaries tom no there's nothing
out here
and then like sometimes i get kind of
drunk on the show and then the next day
i'll wake up and be like what the [ __ ]
did i say oh yeah did i say anything
really bad
in japan they had [ __ ] vending
machines with girls underwear
i've heard that evidently but everything
that's like only where the pervs were
[ __ ] underwear sniffers dudes
sniffing on there they don't even know
what that girl looks like
they're another girl that's just it
doesn't matter nasty it's all about this
nasty [ __ ] which
like i said hey i'm not judging yeah
okay i'm not judging
they're not killing anybody they're not
eating anybody it's
harmless it's gross but it's harmless
you know what i'm saying
they're offering [ __ ] 50.
[Laughter]
oh so gross that's like going back to
like where you were saying about the
moonpie [ __ ] lady yeah moonpie
seriously i was i had been i was a
little bit inebriated when we were
watching that show
and they they just had to like rub it in
because they're just like she has all
these like big like you know apple juice
bottles or whatever
like full of fasting full of her [ __ ]
and whatever and they're just like
laying in the house laying in the yard
whatever yeah and they showed like the
the cleaning people like emptying them
like into the thing and i was just like
i
i had a blanket i was like no no
i was just like that i couldn't watch it
i was just like [ __ ] i was they
weren't legal they weren't
it wasn't legal to send it to the dumps
so they had to [ __ ] unscrew those
caps and they were like in this [ __ ]
biohazard [ __ ] gear with [ __ ]
respirators
and they [ __ ] had they had to get it
down pour the potty over with all that
chemical [ __ ]
all the chemical stuff in there and they
were on i'm [ __ ] unscrewing the tops
of those things and pouring them out
into the ketchup
how could you honestly like [ __ ] i
salute the people that do those [ __ ]
extreme cleaning jobs because
i would just be gagging i really
couldn't believe that they did that in
one porta potty because
there were so many of those containers
that would have been several
hundred gallons well they maybe they
edited it to look like i mean because
i'm sure that it
they couldn't have poured all those out
into one no there's no way there's no
way
because her whole [ __ ] her house was
full of them and her yard was full
yeah that would have been [ __ ] at
least 300 gallons because it's like how
many how long have you been doing that i
mean
years years and years if you're like you
know giving
an estimate that you poop once a day
maybe she was nasty
you know and you're pooping in a bot i
don't know how many poops it takes to
fill up a bottle
uh pro i bet you that was about three or
four days per bottle
i would think can't believe we got on
this [ __ ] time you did some [ __ ]
thank you matt we start talking about
poops and bottles that we get
thanks man thanks man and i'm just like
if you talk about it too much i'm going
to start
giving a hundred dollars for brown
underwear god damn
i don't even think i have any of that
jesus christ jesus christ jesus christ
remember [ __ ] south park [ __ ]
slave
jesus christ jesus christ jesus christ
yeah i don't i don't know well i know
somebody
that she doesn't like seller underwear
or anything like that but she does know
a guy that will just
and this is like it's you know compared
to like [ __ ] feet and
dirty underwear and [ __ ] like that this
is almost like uh wholesome
but there's a guy that she knows that
will pay
for pictures of her and like not even
naked or anything she just like that had
just like with a tight t-shirt on
yeah you know who it is too you know
yeah she's a good-looking woman
and she's married and the husband is
sucking in on this [ __ ] tight t-shirt
[ __ ]
some weird [ __ ] [ __ ] man if somebody
paid me 200 for a picture man inside too
well
everybody everybody can see me in a
tight t-shirt
so why would anybody pay 200 like
[ __ ]
here's the deal though here's the deal
though that's what they told
us there's gotta be more there's more of
that story
guarantee knowing that couple there's
more to that story well there might be
yeah yeah
but on the other hand some people will
pay for very weird specific things
that that's just what they told us yeah
so i don't know well i'm just
going out of the information i was given
i'm a man of the world
oh and i'm not no well i'm not a man
you're not a man of the world but
you know i'm a man of the world and i
read between the lines
there's more to it than what they told
us
yeah i don't know but like i said if
anybody wants my dirty ass shoes that's
just what he told us you want to pay me
a couple hundred dollars for my dirty
ass shoes you can have this
pookie loves them though she loves she
loves to try to climb into my shoes i
don't know why
they smell terrible but yeah so so she's
doing porn
like i said her whole thing was uh
unconscious
women that was kind of like the fetish
did she fake it or was she getting real
women
well i'm i think that it was faked
i don't know for sure probably was it's
easier to fake it than
well yeah because it seems like it'd be
entirely too much trouble
right because women that do porn they're
like hey we want you to pretend that
you've been drugged
it's like a lot of a lot of the weird
[ __ ] that you see in porn is fake
not all of it of course a lot of it is
fake um like
as ron jeremy okay [ __ ] i saw a thing
where they showed ron and jeremy the two
girls
one cup video and jeremy just goes oh
yeah well that's fake
and they're going no no it's not fake he
goes no no no that's fake
i said two girls and it turned out later
on i've never seen it but i heard i
[ __ ] there's a [ __ ] channel called
wang i read
the chinese kind of it and i'm like yeah
it's fake i'm not gonna it turned out it
is fake it's fake
even if it is watching it but ron jeremy
called it i saw a video of ron jeremy's
reaction to it and he's like
no no no no it's so much easier to
[ __ ] just fake that stuff
yeah well that's what i mean anything
like that it just seems like it's easier
to fake it yeah
because the thing about it is that i
know there are people that are into like
scat porn that are into [ __ ] like that
but it just seems like it would be so
much easier you it would be easier to
get
actors to be in the movie if it wasn't
real right
because you're only going to get like a
tiny tiny tiny percentage of porn
actors willing to do stat horn for
example yeah
like um there are some that i think is
real but that particular video that i
was talking about
two girls one cup that particular cut of
what was happening
right was faked and
it turned out they thought it was real
for a long time but then they showed
showed it to ron jeremy and his reaction
was oh no that would be easy to fake
that's fake
yeah why do that for real well most
things are easy yeah
so okay and they do it during the during
the edit
but uh deborah says wow just came in
here poops in a bottle
yeah yeah sorry we're talking it's
overwhelming
yeah wait you know this is this is why i
have literally
[ __ ] unconscious molestation porn
yeah yeah i think think of how what
which is related to the case that we're
talking about it's not that
think about it think about trouble you
got to go through to get somebody and
then drug them and then take a picture
of them being molested and [ __ ]
it's it's easier just to fake that
well yeah i mean especially especially
something like that yeah because like
you can't if you gave somebody like real
[ __ ] that would make them unconscious
it's like you don't know how they're
going to react
what if they're allergic they might die
they might overdose but they might see
the pictures later on and sue you
so it's just like i didn't know what was
going on so it's like it's easier just
to fake it right
i mean yeah you get a girl who's [ __ ]
willing to do porn says look you don't
have to really do porn
just pretend like you're knocked out and
we'll make a [ __ ] million bucks
and she's like okay how are you going to
find me all right and then they just
fake it that's all
that's a good thing and like i said
something like scat porn it's like it
just seems like much easier
most of it i'm sure there's real scat
porn but i know there's a real scat worn
out yeah but i'm just saying
that in you know on the more mainstream
end it would be much easier to get
actors if it wasn't real [ __ ]
because how many people are gonna get
that one evidently one fetish one where
they're eating
eating vomit and [ __ ] vomit and then
eating vomit
and can't some of that's real some of
that's real but evidently a lot of
that's faked it's it's fake didn't edit
i just can't like somebody might really
somebody might really throw up
somebody might get down pretend like
they're going to eat it but then they
cut to a close-up
and that's not real vomit that right you
know what i mean so it's all in the edit
yeah it's just like it's just like cream
corn out of a can yeah
and if you guys are [ __ ] want to see
a cool movie on this subject go see that
one [ __ ] movie what's the name of
that one
mo mope was a genius movie
that shit's [ __ ] streaming and it's a
true story yeah it just came out this
year
yeah bottom of the barrel porn yeah and
[ __ ] a bad [ __ ] murder happens
but yeah like it's based on a true story
but it's good it's good
we reviewed it a while back yeah but
yeah i really i really liked that movie
i'm kind of fascinated by the porn
industry you know what i mean yeah
even though i'm not really that
fascinated with porn itself but i'm it's
mostly
everything most of that [ __ ] would be a
grind it'd be just like something out of
moped well that's what i mean it would
just
it's it's funny to me i think maybe
that's why i find it fascinating is that
you know you you have people that are
like obsessed with it and want to watch
it all the time
but it's like for the people that are
doing it it's just a job it's a job they
don't give a [ __ ] and they don't really
give a [ __ ] and it's like they're just
doing it for the
for a paycheck and it's like viagra to
get into it yeah they just turn up one
day
like uh what do we got to do today just
like every other job you know and i mean
it's not like
a lot of times i feel like a job it
would become a [ __ ] daily grind
[ __ ]
real quick yeah yeah i feel like it
would just be like any other
horrible job that you don't want to go
to and she's like oh man i gotta be up
there with a telemarketing job i gotta
get [ __ ] by like three different
dudes
that's right oh it's a gang bang
yeah i'm gonna need some liquor when i
get home yeah that's it you know what
it's going to be like that
there's still [ __ ] bidding on your
[ __ ] operation
god damn it why didn't i think of this
[ __ ] before we could have like auctioned
off
underwear yeah alex rivera's going thank
god that's a [ __ ] fake fitness yeah
yeah ron jeremy [ __ ] saw him goes oh
that's fake
i hope it's fake dude like i said i'm
still not watching it because
even if it's fake i'm still grossed out
ron
ron the hedgehog man the motherfucker's
a damn legend he's a cool dude and he's
got a [ __ ] great rum
it's called ron ron de jeremy ron de
jeremy rhonda jeremy because
rum is actually spelled ron in cuba yeah
rhonda jeremy it's [ __ ] great
great rum they still sell that i think
so
i think so i can't i didn't look for it
last time it's real good
and uh you don't need to mix it with
anything just on the rocks just sipping
rum
really good it is pretty weird remember
we had that at that one one club
yeah we had it at stake it was [ __ ]
good it's real spicy because i was like
ron did jeremy he has his own wrong okay
yeah he's on the black hole [ __ ] he's on
lane he looks all classy and [ __ ]
yeah yeah i was like oh my god yeah he's
in a tuxedo looking at you like he's a
[ __ ] connoisseur
gourmet it's looking great yeah i know
everything about everything and it
wasn't cheap though
it was it was pretty expensive
pretty expensive sipping whiskey just
sipping rum ah
yeah all right so uh so this woman in
addition to running all of these
internet businesses she got the
decoration
she got the psychic stuff she got the
porn unconscious
women poor and stuff um she also
was into some weird [ __ ] of her own so
uh
would go on a lot of message boards uh
you know
porn message boards trying to like get
her jollies that way
um so she was on she had she was uh
regular on a foot fetish site of course
also on like a bondage site and uh it
came to light later on after what
happened happened
uh that she had a whole bunch of posts
talking about how badly she wanted to be
tortured to death
that's a weird [ __ ] yeah that was like
her big fantasy
yeah so um you know like i said no
judging
but weird it's a little weird i gotta
take another break
holy i have not taken him i have not
taken a single break
look at this look at that i'm a man
my [ __ ] bladder is like the size of a
lemon
i think it's much smaller than a lemon
so yeah so she's on all these messages
talking about
how much she wants to get tortured to
death because that was kind of her thing
um she also like the character that she
played
like on in her porn life i guess like
all the porn businesses she ran and like
all the um messages that she posted on
like various
porn sites so her kind of
um you know her alternate identity uh
nancy carlson i think yeah nancy carlson
nancy carlson
was a 300 pound
dominatrix so you know what i mean even
that's not really what
the real woman looked like um she was a
little
chubby but she wasn't 300 pounds or
nothing and
she didn't look like a dominatrix she
just looked like a regular person
um you know she just looked like a mom
or something so
that was like her alternate identity i
guess
so like i said she wants to get
tortured to death so one person
that she starts talking to is
this guy named robert bobby
glass now he was a computer analyst
and he worked for catawba county north
carolina he had been working there for
about 16 years
so uh he was also married he had a wife
named sherry
and they had three kids two girls and
one boy
now over this time period
uh bobby's wife sherry notices that he's
spending an
awfully lot of time on the computer
and wonders what the [ __ ] he's up to
um turns out that he was on like a whole
bunch of
porn sites like sherry snooped after a
while because i guess it was just
getting egregious and she couldn't take
it anymore
so she goes into his email account and
she finds like a whole bunch of messages
that he had been sending
under some pseudonyms and i love you
guys are gonna love this
his pseudonyms were slow hand
because of course and toy man
i feel like slow hand is a really
common like alias
for these types of dudes am i wrong
about that because i feel like this is
not the only person
that i've heard of in this type of
situation
that had that screen name you know what
i'm saying
i feel like these are like all old
classic rock kind of eric clapton kind
of fans
and slow hand is kind of like has has a
sexual connotation so they think they're
being like clever
but they don't know that they're not the
only person that's done that
i don't know i could be totally wrong
about that but
yeah so he's posting all these messages
under slow hand and toy man
on all these porn sites so
i guess his wife found like all these
emails where
that he had exchanged with sharon lopez
about
her torture fetish 900 pages of emails
were found after the murder
so these people had been talking about
this
a lot so what ends up happening
sharon finally decides i guess much like
burn did in the case of the cannibal
thing
which she's like okay today is the day
i'm gonna get tortured to death
that's weird [ __ ] man can you imagine
like how how do you wake up one morning
and say today's the day i'm going to
fulfill my fantasy of being tortured to
death
but she must have done that because she
planned it they had dude that's so
[ __ ] weird to me they had dudes
throughout the century
sitting in [ __ ] prison cells waiting
to go out to the [ __ ] gallows and get
hung
in [ __ ] dread right okay that dude's
a [ __ ] death row
right going [ __ ] oh [ __ ] one day
that's all in your mind
you'll just be in your mind everything
those dudes were just gonna get hung
or lethal injection which is quick yeah
she's like going no i want to get
tortured it's just some weird [ __ ]
like i get weird like look i get state
of masochism i get it
okay yeah but the idea of not coming
back from right
but it's like you know you want a little
bit of pain it's like you know that's
cool it's like you know i i totally
understand that a lot of people are
interested in this [ __ ] [ __ ] right
that's not weird at all yeah but the
fact that you would want to get like
actually tortured until you die that's
some cinnabite action
right that's like some [ __ ] out of the
center bites
yeah man why didn't she meet the center
but it's had a little turn
the center bites she even like give me
that box but it's like but it's [ __ ]
foreign
it's forever you die and then you go off
into the damn that's what i'm saying
that's that's one thing that kind of
bothers
me about this is that it's one thing to
have a sexual fantasy and to like
fantasize about to write about it
to think about it to talk to other
people about it but then to actually do
it and know that you're not going to be
able to do it again
you know what i mean it's only going to
be one time
like what i don't i can't put myself
into that mindset i guess
michael's michael shaffer said yeah
hallowed be thy name was about that
that's an
iron maiden song yeah yeah i'm waiting
in my cold
cell when the bell begins to chime
i'm singing okay go ahead the nick cave
song the mercy seat was also about
that it was about well actually that was
about a murderer that was in the
electric chair
yeah it was like his last thoughts while
he was in the election yeah
you see here's the thing
i totally relate to dudes waiting to go
into battle
all right to kick some [ __ ] ass and
probably [ __ ] get killed in the act
but you're going to be with your boys
during this you know what i mean
yeah you're not the only one you're not
alone right and this isn't [ __ ]
punishment
this is something that you've been
training for this this is the big game
right yeah i mean and you and your unit
are going to [ __ ] make a point
and you might not die you might not die
it's not assert it's not so right
okay a good example would be d-day that
invasion that was a badass [ __ ]
battle
because they were waiting for it they
could see it on the horizon coming up
while they're on the landing craft
some of them never made it off the
landing craft the [ __ ] landing crafts
were just [ __ ] riddled with machine
gun bullets to kill them all
you know but you don't know and none of
those dudes died alone
but this whole concept of [ __ ] being
executed
that's very very different it's not a
naturalistic
there isn't a kind of an emotional drive
behind it
maybe this woman had that the same
emotional drive
like storming the beaches of normandy
but i don't think so i just don't think
so the adrenaline isn't there
maybe i don't that's what i mean because
this seems like i mean this is a long
term yeah because she's been talking to
this dude for like 900 pages worth of
[ __ ]
maybe it's just planning this the
ultimate thinking about it the ultimate
in masochism
of just you know yeah okay yeah kill me
kill me
that's just that's just [ __ ] some
weird [ __ ] which like i said i guess i
can see casino masochism like i said is
not
really all that strange because you know
pain and pleasure they're very close
together
but they're playing it's but it's play
acting and like you know that you say
the safe word and they stop
but it's like i so there's got to be
like a small
percentage of that type of people that
take it
to the ultimate extreme because they're
always going to tell me to sing it
[ __ ] awesome i have plans look michael
i have plans to [ __ ]
jenny can attest to this to do a cover
album to release to y'all
one of these days yeah get around to it
that's right it was going to have
sisters of mercy covers
it was going to have [ __ ] um uh
judas priest covers i was gonna sing old
[ __ ] like off of sin after sin
you know like dissident aggressor and
[ __ ] i was gonna sing like that and i'll
probably put some iron maiden in there
man but i gotta get like some karaoke
style
yeah but yeah maybe one of these days
i'll release
i'll release some singles we'll put that
[ __ ] in the stream i have right over
there right here okay
because i got a sound booth i have a
little sound with a good microphone
where i do my audio
yeah we have like the even better
microphone in there yeah the scarlet
zolo yeah and i had to get back in
training because i am a trained vocalist
i could do it [ __ ] you know what i
mean
yeah you got to do your take take me a
few weeks to get back into it but
yeah you got to do your little
practicing scales and get back to it
yeah but actually i i wasn't so much
thinking about
iron man and i wanted to do some rob i
want to do some rob halford
now you know he's the god [ __ ] rob
halford is a [ __ ] metal god i can't
hit all that but
some of those [ __ ] some of those
songs i could do the older ones
yeah yeah that [ __ ] can sing
yeah no [ __ ]
he was like freddie mercury it was that
level of vocalist
in terms in the metal world although i'd
probably say that [ __ ] freddie
mercury was actually a little bit better
but
i think freddie mercury that was like a
once in a lifetime like a once in a
generation [ __ ] was [ __ ]
voice insanely talented i mean that was
like an incredible insanely talented he
had an incredible voice
yeah and there was and he had a good uh
stage presence and he had a good yeah
everything just came together in one
individual that hardly ever happened
yeah and on stage he would just
assume an identity to sing a song like
he was like
like singing you know we are the
champions he would be in one role and
then he would go to [ __ ] you know
the one about [ __ ] uh you know
machine guns ready to go
you know what was the name of that
[ __ ] song um another one
another one bites the dust yeah you
could tell that the way he carried
himself he was doing two different
characters
yeah you know so he was he was i don't
want to go
off on that man uh i got a
deep deep respect for freddie mercury we
just watched freddie mercury documentary
the other day he was what they call a
power bisexual
he was [ __ ] power bisexual yeah
yeah and then [ __ ] it's funny i
didn't realize it but now i'm talking
about two
two [ __ ] alternate [ __ ] sexuality
kind of dudes you know what i mean but
second
but you know they those dudes [ __ ]
suffered a lot
and through that suffering they were
able to muster the creative energy and
that creative energy
they could express themselves that was
the medium of the day
well sometimes yeah i need it's terrible
that like because a lot of people that
produce great art they must suffer well
and they suffer because of the type of
temperament that they have
right you know what i mean so it's like
they're never going to be
happy they're never going to be if you
have a if you have a good and happy life
it's hard for you to create meaningful
yeah because you don't really have any
incentives yeah there's got to be
conflict
yeah you have to have like some kind of
like whether it's inner conflict doesn't
have to be outer conflict is you i mean
your life doesn't have to be horrible
but you have to have something
they got people that talk bad about neat
nietzsche and nietzsche and philosophy
but all that [ __ ] falls within
what nietzsche was talking about uh you
know
uh rob both rob halford and [ __ ]
um uh dude from queen i'm [ __ ] drunk
i can't remember [ __ ]
what's uh yeah freddie murphy yeah they
were nichian figures
uh and and that's why the quality of
their art was good
yeah so not good they're great
greatness comes from that kind of stuff
overcoming obstacles
that which was the which does not kill
you makes you stronger
and uh albums
for some of you guys are too too young
to to know
the old world our generation we're x
generation and we have a foot in both
the old world and a new world
the old world didn't have the internet
we had albums
that was the internet of our generation
you knew what was going on based upon
music
because television wasn't as controlled
tell you know excuse me television was
highly controlled albums weren't
so that was kind of like our version of
the internet
so in a lot of ways these old rock stars
and
the idea of a rock star really isn't
even around anymore but
rock stars of that era were kind of like
well i don't want to say the [ __ ]
youtuber but almost kind of like the
youtuber of the time
of those days yeah because i mean
nowadays
you now have youtubers are [ __ ]
actually
in ascendance right now i mean you have
hollywood stars
trying to become youtubers now isn't
that something
because of the amount of influence yeah
which
it's amazing but
the medium has been punk rockified not
wrong with that nothing wrong with that
at all we were there for that
for that yeah like i said so that was
really inspirational to me
yeah as a kid because i you know i came
of age like right
around the time that that all that [ __ ]
was happening and for me to realize
that you can make music you can make a
movie you can write a book you don't
need
no like this but you don't need a lot of
money you don't need this four kids are
becoming famous
right and it's like that was like a big
deal to me like
you know growing up in a trailer park
like i did it was kind of like a big
deal
susie from susan the banshee came from
nothing [ __ ] the sex pistols from
nothing
worse than nothing those guys were
[ __ ] poverty yeah uh [ __ ] billy
idol
[ __ ] you know i mean he was awesome
came from nothing really
duran duran from they came from nothing
nothing they were pretty birthday those
dudes [ __ ] ended up becoming some of
the most influential [ __ ] richest
dudes of our era though
and they all married supermodels and
they were the first boy band really
but they were so much more than a boy
but substance they actually yeah
more like the beatles they could write
songs they could write songs in lyrics
yeah yeah duran drama was almost kind of
like the beatles of our generation yeah
they were [ __ ] excellent super good
sandra says stephen king wrote his best
books in my opinion when he was still on
drugs and alcohol i agree also
um honestly i've liked some of his newer
stuff but
gotta say when he was on coke and he's
like i don't even remember writing that
i'm like well
it's still good though i mean that's
pretty good
because i feel like what happens with a
lot of writers and i've i have the same
problem
i feel like i couldn't really finish a
story or like write anything
until i stopped thinking about it i
don't really have to
get drunk to write because then just
like [ __ ] [ __ ] goes all over the
place
but what i started doing like for what
alex rivera said that steven seagal
famously suffers
i was gonna say that but it already
scrolled up by the time he stopped
talking so i didn't yeah oh that
[ __ ] suffers to make those
movies he really
along the lines of [ __ ] kubrick yeah
but yeah so when i actually started like
finishing stories and finishing novels
when i started doing it i know this is
gonna sound weird
but i started doing like almost an
automatic writing thing
like i would buy a notebook every time i
was gonna start a new story
and then i would just open it and it's
like i'd have an idea and then i would
just
start writing and i would like not try
not to look at the page
um unless i absolutely had to
jim trucker man he's saying he's a truck
driver and he just wanted to thank us
because he's listening to us on the road
[ __ ]
listen what we're doing oh awesome okay
man [ __ ] you got you know i've said
it before on the show man [ __ ] that
uh truckers are the backbone
of the united states economy well they
really are you guys move everything
you guys are the infantry of this we
just sit in our houses and order things
yeah
long you're doing that bob sega [ __ ] you
know
the open road in lot lizards i
understand bro
[ __ ] doing your time stop my waffle
house holy [ __ ] yeah
i thought that was gone i'm being asked
being asked can i scream like rob
halford yeah i can't but i'm in
when i'm up to snuff and i haven't
really been up to stuff in years but
i could probably get myself back into
the condition where i can do all that so
yeah let's see there's some other
questions like i said you need to get
some uh
do some vocal training oh uh talking
about
uh ken fetter said friends growing up
knew that freddie was gay
and didn't like him man they were
crushed when they heard that rob was gay
too
but hell he started the metal look yeah
that's true rob halford
actually when he started rob halford
looked kind of like a whimsical hippie
with these damn robes and a long blonde
hair
whimsical hippie whimsical hippie yeah
he looked like something that's
my new hipster indy band
that band looked like [ __ ] kind of
like a damn
led zeppelin wannabes really is what
they what they look like
but man the lyrics were [ __ ] badass
and so was the music especially by
by the time sin after uh sin after sin
came out
but rob you know he he followed his
instincts he saw those [ __ ] gay
leather daddies with the [ __ ]
motorcycle little [ __ ] hats and
the [ __ ] sleeveless jackets with the
spikes and [ __ ] he's like man that's
what really looks good
that's what metal should look like and
yeah he invented
he said [ __ ] it the metal look
is the leather daddy look and i agreed
with him well the thing about it is that
if you want metal to be subversive
that's what it has to be
right yeah you have to make people
uncomfortable
yeah and homosexuality made people
uncomfortable well it was
it was also at the time it was also the
[ __ ]
the aggressive male sexuality yeah it
wasn't so much the homosexuality was the
fact that it was a subversive male
sexuality it could it was i wouldn't
it was a gay look in the day
okay it was yeah they innovated it yeah
but
he made it more mainstream he was like
uh
no a guy can look like this yeah yeah i
mean so
you had to watch yourself if you look
like that you know what i mean but
that's
that's that's what you know that's what
i mean yeah if you look like that in
daytona when i was growing up you'd get
your butt kicked it depended
depends because real soon
a few seemingly a few years later you
had [ __ ] vince neil and nikki sixx
and all those guys that were straight as
[ __ ]
and motley crew wearing their
girlfriend's leather clothes yeah
i mean that was their girlfriend's
clothes wearing that [ __ ] they were
wearing
their girlfriend's clothes right
anything that's like not even an
exaggeration
exactly that was their girlfriend
absolutely they were borrowing their
girls their girlfriends were doing their
hair and doing their [ __ ] eyeliner
but let's be honest let's be honest
about the dudes from motley crue hanging
out now they
they were comfortable with their
sexuality yes because they had women
yeah women were throwing themselves at
him yeah you weren't going to accuse
these dudes of being gay because they
were [ __ ] with porn stars
because they were just like on a pile of
paper they were on a pile of poon
so they kind of had license to look like
that
so it was kind of like the horseshoe
effect
you can get you start off gay but you
just keep going until it comes back
around straight again
that's what it was which i respect your
[ __ ] game
i respect you that's what i mean you can
get away with like certain things but
then you gotta ask yourself was that a
white thing did white guys innovate that
because there were some
black dudes that were doing the same
thing [ __ ] prince was doing that
all right prince if you ask me prince
was [ __ ] straight i think he was
aggressively [ __ ] straight yeah but
if you were to look at it from
everything i heard
yeah but if you were to look at him you
might think that he was gay if he didn't
understand that that was prince
although that i that really never
occurred to me like i never thought
i always saw him as straight i did too
because we were young when we saw him
yeah older people would have thought
that maybe he was gay yeah but that
i i kind of feel like when mtv first
came around like my grandparents and
stuff because i [ __ ] loved mtv man
and i just like watched all the time i
was really into new wave and stuff
i mean my grandparents were like they
thought they were all gay yeah so you
know
and then you could also say that [ __ ]
rick james might have
come across that way if you didn't
understand it but rick james was a
[ __ ] dog
rich rick rick james was straight uh
or i mean in the 80s he might have just
been pansexual i don't [ __ ] that's
what i mean he might have just hit
anything
like i said it's a continuum you know
it's like you can't just like put people
into one box or another because some
people will just like go after
yeah what if it's like what i don't care
what that is it just looks good
so you know now we're going back on
freddie mercury because he said freddie
mercury
freddie mercury was not gay uh freddie
mercury was bisexual
but leaned more towards gay that's how i
understood it
i thought that as well yeah i think
there were some i think he did like some
women
but well i mean the love of his life was
a woman
yeah but i mean he left him he left her
all his money and stuff like that
but yeah but like i said that's why we
have
like i said that's why it's a continuum
you can't really like
some dudes are just a certain people
just like what they like some dudes are
just a certain way
and if they're [ __ ] giving us
enjoyment in the form of [ __ ] music
and art and [ __ ]
as i'm straight but i'm saying that i'm
gonna [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] up because i
can understand it
yeah you know what i mean he's
freddie mercury can speak to me [ __ ]
uh uh you know rob halford rob
speaks to me you know i'm like i
understand where rob is coming from
you know [ __ ] i'd have to be careful
around rob
rob might try to put the move on a
pretty [ __ ] like me especially
back in the day
but i i'm i can defend myself
but there was a lot of them that were
like that adamant i thought he was
[ __ ]
i thought he was gay he wasn't gay no he
wasn't good well that's what i mean i
feel like
back in like i said back in the 80s when
it was very like hip
yeah to be gender-based it was kind of
ambiguous
or you know gender ambiguous so that was
like kind of very that was a very big
thing
so it's like you couldn't really tell
but i mean to me
it's like it never really i don't know i
just didn't think about it i was just
like what
duran duran whatever or if they're not i
don't care
duran duran had the ambiguous look but i
could tell right from the lyrics that
those dudes were all [ __ ] i knew they
were all strange they were all straight
they were all straight they were
straight they had good quality [ __ ]
the only person
i didn't guess about um george michael i
guess i never i wasn't hugely into wham
so i didn't know i thought george
michael was straight
i didn't really think about it i thought
he was [ __ ] straight i didn't really
think about it
um i called boy george but that's yeah i
thought that was obvious
yeah i thought it was obviously he was
gay yeah yeah that's what i mean that
was pretty much the only one that
like stood out as obvious like the rest
of them i was just kind of like meh
crap they're still hot so i don't care i
don't care
[Laughter]
now the dudes cause i like that i like
that sexual ambiguity dudes from iron
maiden
to me they were all straight i could
tell well i think everybody thought that
yeah
i think everybody thought that and i
think like when ron halford came
out i think everybody like well not
everybody but like a lot of people
like wigged out no you see here's here's
the deal
i was paying close attention to those
lyrics all right
from from from from judas priest you
hear like the island of
domination and raw deal and i'm like
those are gay lyrics well yeah listening
to them now it's like
super obvious that that's what he's
talking about he's talking about other
dudes
dudes [ __ ] twisting in the mirror and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and and [ __ ] you know
and putting another [ __ ] in her
place it's like this all this damn
powerful domination and [ __ ] going on
between men
and i'm going and he said fire island
and i'm like well that should have been
like a big clue right there so he wasn't
really hiding it
no he just it's just the lyrics were not
i mean maybe maybe straight people
didn't know about fire island
yeah the lyrics were not written down
inside the album coverage
in the album jacket you had to pay
attention he says wait a minute hold on
he said fire island
yeah that's that was gay hangout yeah so
i was like he's gay and that was kind of
like that was some verse that was some
subversive [ __ ] in the early 80s that's
what i'm saying that's pretty surprising
like that's what he said
but and i was having a hard time making
the [ __ ] connection between the
village people
and [ __ ] and and jesus priest but now
the
connection was right there man but i
mean
it was a european gay so america's had a
hard time [ __ ] comprehending
well americans have a hard time it was
yeah it was a european game we didn't
comprehend they were kind of idiots they
were a few years ahead of us
in terms of what was allowed in the
media yeah because we we were censored
basically yeah yeah well because
i don't know it's america's always been
very weird to me because it always just
seems like very very schizophrenic
you know what i mean it's like we're
really really backwards in some ways
yeah but then we're like really really i
don't know oh
crazy [ __ ] you mentioned duran duran i
gotta say yasmin labon
she is pretty hot i gotta say although i
was like a teenager when they got
married and i was so bad because simon
was my favorite and i was just like you
[ __ ]
you took simon away from me i was like
12. i mean to be honest
mike was going would you let the crus
will put the move on you tom
there's some [ __ ] crustle could i film
it
first thing first of all that's the
bigger question first of all this [ __ ]
would never happen because crosstalk
wouldn't do that
crust was straight as [ __ ] all right but
no no he's straight
but no uh i'm drunk enough no no
no crustal would not be my type
you sure now you've got me like
look at this you're exciting jenny
you're exciting jenny no
[ __ ] no i gotta go to the restaurant
now here i'm just
i'm just mad that like i couldn't
fulfill my fantasy of you and david
bowie because he died
yeah that's sad
that was one of the first things just
like after like i was super sad when
david bowie died seriously we were at
[ __ ] eye bar
yeah and they were playing a bunch of
david bowie songs like it was just a day
or two after he died and i was just like
i was crying my [ __ ] eyes out
you know i was really upset and like he
was like now you're just bummed out that
you that me and david will never have
sex and you can't film it
i was like that's not why i'm crying but
that is a bummer
what was so funny about [ __ ] bowie
before he died
before he died or at his death
his official [ __ ] statement to the
public was is that
don't tell them no don't tell them i was
a closeted heterosexual
he was like [ __ ] was funny
[ __ ] class right to the end
i [ __ ] loved that i loved that that
was some oscar wilde [ __ ] he pulled
right there
all right oh my god i feel like i have
to sneeze all right
unless he was cremated it's still
possible yeah but you know how you know
tom and his necrophilia thing
it's just not and i don't think it'd be
the same if it was like
i can't believe how far this show has
devolved
all right so let's get back i totally
forgot what we were even talking about
so they're in a chat room like i said
this woman sharon lopez she wants to be
tortured to death that's her sexual
fantasy and i guess she's into it so
whatever
so she's been talking to this dude named
bobby glass and
so morning of october 13 1996
so sharon leaves a note well she tells
her husband
she's like hey i'm going down to georgia
to like hang out with some friends of
mine
okay that's what she told him to his
face but then she left a note for him to
find
later like after he was after she was
gone
now the note said that she wasn't
coming back because obviously she was
gonna be dead
um and she also said to not
look for the person that killed her
basically
is like don't look for that guy don't
look for this guy
that's what she said in the note so she
leaves
um oh and the note also said if my body
is never retrieved
don't worry know that i'm at know that
i'm at peace
so basically she said she was going away
and she was gonna die
and but don't worry about it is
essentially what she said
so she drives to pennsylvania station in
baltimore
and then she takes the amtrak to
charlotte
north carolina and then bobby glass
picks her
up and they go to his
mobile home in north carolina
which is about 80 miles outside of
charlotte in some little little town
so meanwhile uh
sharon's husband victor finds the note
and calls the cops like you would
because she basically said hey i'm going
off somewhere and i'm gonna
die so the cops came and they went
through all her [ __ ]
and they found all of the email
correspondence between her and bobby
glass
basically saying like setting up the
whole hey i'm gonna torture you to death
scenario
so the cops um
they so they call the cops in north
carolina they stake out
uh bobby's mobile home right
now they sit outside the house for
several days i guess they didn't have a
surge horn or whatever so they couldn't
go in there
so they sit outside the mobile home for
a few days but they didn't see anybody
they didn't see
sharon they didn't see anybody so
finally the judge
issues a search warrant so the cops can
go inside
and when the cops go inside and search
the trailer
they find like a whole bunch of sharon
lapotka's stuff
in there um they also found some bondage
stuff
they found some drugs and they found a
bunch of child porn
so there you go they found some guns
they found like a bunch of computer
disks which they took off for later
perusal
um and then one of the cops says
hey there's a suspicious looking pile of
dirt
over there behind the trailer so let's
go check that out let's say
so they go and check that out and they
find a bunch of body parts buried behind
the trailer two and a half feet under
this little
pile of soil so they arrest bobby glass
now bobby glass even if he had got off
for the consensual murder of sharon
lapotka
he would still be going to prison
because his trailer was just full of
child porn
so you know not exactly i might have
missed it
how did he exactly torture her uh he
didn't that's the thing
it's like i feel like she just got there
and they had gone through like 900 pages
of emails of them
setting this whole thing up and
fantasizing about it and then she gets
there
when they found the body it didn't look
like she'd been tortured
it basically just looked like maybe they
did like some light bonded [ __ ] and then
he just strangled her and threw her in a
hole in the backyard
you made it easy on her i maybe yeah i
mean you know
right how would i know that
you say you know well no i mean it's
just that's just a
i think he made it easier on her yeah
it's like i don't
so again he got to a point where he's
sitting there and he's doing his bondage
thing you know
and all of a sudden he goes this is the
right time this is the right moment
and you know what i mean she's having a
good time now it's time to [ __ ] go
ahead and finish this [ __ ] off
and maybe that's what he did and he
chokes her out
so it wasn't like like a cinebite style
torture to death where you're ripping
somebody apart whether you're ripping
their face off and you're just like
skinning her alive which i don't i
haven't read her emails so i don't know
like how severe her torture from like i
don't know what kind of torture she's
talking about
maybe yeah maybe maybe he read what she
would talked about and so he did what
what she wanted yeah it's like so i
don't know she wanted torture like hey
rip my limbs off burn me alive like you
know ears off
cut my ears off like waterboard me i
don't know like i don't know like what
the extent of her torture fantasy was
so maybe he did do that but they're just
saying they didn't find anything on her
that would
suggest that she had been tortured
before she died it just looked like
she had been strangled and that's it
so i don't really know if this dude was
just like hey here's somebody i can just
kill and not [ __ ]
worry about it or if this is another
case where just as in the previous case
where brandeis goes to he's like hey
i've had this lifelong fantasy of like
being
killed and eaten and then they try to
eat his dick and they can't even do that
right and then he's all like all bummed
out
like it's a big bummer and it's like
this is the only time this is gonna
happen
and it's messed up you know what i mean
so i kind of maybe this was the same
situation she like built this all up in
her mind
i'm gonna get tortured he's gonna rip my
limbs off he's gonna burn me alive like
a witch at salem and all this other kind
of stuff
although they got they got hung they
didn't get burned but um
you know what i mean so so maybe she had
this
to death well that one guy did dials
corey but um
he got pressed under rocks and he said
more weight yeah and they can't put it i
was like that it's badass and
he's trying to get get it over with he's
like yeah it's just like
get this [ __ ] away can you just stop
it's like this is like okay
but yeah so it's like maybe she had this
big elaborate fantasy and then she got
there and the dude was like too lazy to
do it
and then she's like man [ __ ] you i
wanted this that and the other thing and
he's like man i want to do that
and then you strangled her yeah i kind
of feel like that's probably more likely
maybe
because you know the dudes do they're
just like yeah you know dudes dude they
get finished
they're just like lazy they're lazy they
[ __ ] get themselves finished and then
they [ __ ] right
so i kind of feel like he got off and
then he's like man i don't want to do
all that [ __ ] it's like
too much work i don't want to i don't
want to cut off all your fingers one by
one and i don't want to do all that i'm
talking about bowie jagger and angie
yeah well i think iggy pop might have
been in there too
ooh never that one iggy was also [ __ ]
uh in that mix he seemed rather
pansexual also
yeah he he was like ah you're getting
killed yeah yeah maybe she backed out
before it was too late that could be
also
yeah um i'm not you know i'm not really
sure
so yeah so they found all this [ __ ] in
his house so he gets arrested
he gets charged with first-degree murder
and he gets all the charges for the
child porn
now he pleaded guilty to voluntary
manslaughter
and sexual exploitation charges and he
got sentenced to
only 36 to 53 months
which that's not bad that's what six to
eight years and then he got an
additional 27 months
for second-degree minor exploitation
which i guess was for the child porn
yeah okay yeah minor exploitation here
that's all he got
yeah whether did he run it concurrent or
they ran it consecutive
consecutive okay so about 10 years yeah
but
it all ended up being a moot point
anyway because he went to prison
and then a month before he was supposed
to get out he had a heart attack and
died
uh did his time and it died february
2002 but i still feel like
i still feel like that what uh this is
like so
this is this is an upsetting case
because
i i feel like he just didn't get one he
probably should have got more than that
just for the child porn i feel like
yeah you know what i'm saying but the
fact that he killed somebody whether she
wanted to be killed or not
i you know i don't know man it just
seems
i don't know it's just like seems this
is kind of bothering well whatever
[ __ ] that dude he did his time and then
died before he got out
yeah he didn't get out like he's dead
now he died of a heart attack yeah
that's punishment enough but he was like
well i'm gonna get out of here
i'm gonna get out i'm making it i'm
gonna be cool they died i'm coming to
join you elizabeth
and they hit the ground so he went out
the red fox way yeah okay
all the young people like what the [ __ ]
are you even talking about
you have to be old you have to
understand stanford is son
[Laughter]
okay although i do kind of oh my
goodness hi pookie she's like are you
guys still in here oh my goodness
yeah so this case was apparently the
first one where a murder suspect was put
in custody
uh because of evidence from emails
because like i said they found all those
emails like where she was like
describing what she wanted to do and
he's like yeah i'm trying to do that and
blah blah blah
so you know i just i don't know i i feel
like
this case too even though i hadn't heard
of this one
prior to i mean the arm the arm and
myvis case is like super super famous
because like seriously that dude
killed and ate another dude and the dude
was barely okay with it
this woman is like not as you don't hear
as much about it i guess i guess because
it wasn't as splashy
like she didn't get tortured she didn't
get eaten she didn't get anything like
that this dude just
they met each other and then she
strangled her and buried her in the
backyard and it was like yeah there she
is
um so but they did kind of like it did
kind of
open up a discussion about you know
should we allow
these people on these like extreme
fetish websites to have these types of
discussions that might actually lead to
something in the real world
and all this other kind of [ __ ] but
honestly i think it's
better i think it's better than it used
to be because since we have all these
fetish websites now where people can
talk about
their fantasies as [ __ ] up as they are
um
i think that's better i don't think it
encourages people to do it in real life
probably gets it out of their system i
think it gets it out of there you know
you know
there's always going to be that tiny
percentage of people that are just going
to be messed up and they're going to do
this [ __ ] regardless
but i do feel like that would be a
larger percentage
if those people were not allowed to
express
their it'll just desires it'll just
fester and understand that
other people have those desires too and
if they're not
you know they're not necessarily like
ideal
but the fact that other people have them
too like would maybe make you feel less
weird so you wouldn't
feel like so inclined to act on them in
real life
you know what i'm saying i do feel like
it's why nowadays you don't see
quite as many serial killers of the type
that you saw in the 70s and 80s
i think now because people that maybe
before would have become serial killers
because they thought well i'm the only
one that has this like really weird
proclivity um or whatever like now you
can go online you can go on some like
weird message board and you can talk to
other people who have that same thing so
you can feel like you're not
weird you know what i mean you can say
what you want
to me is that shit's still [ __ ] weird
it is weird i'm not saying that yeah
yeah
but you know what i mean get that [ __ ]
out of your sister you have to act on
weird [ __ ]
you know what i mean she got some weird
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you kind of groove with
that weird [ __ ] and then
leave that [ __ ] between yourself all
right don't yeah it's like you wanna
it's just sex why you wanna kill
somebody over [ __ ] sex
right that's some weird and the thing is
is like if you know and if you wanna
write like fanfic about it
and if like if you wanna share like
stories about like where you do that
type of stuff and it's not
real you're not doing it then you know
i'm not gonna read it because it's not
my thing but it's like if other people
want to read it then
i think that's fine as long as you're
not doing it in real life
you know what i mean as long as no real
person yeah talk it out you'll get over
it
because that's just [ __ ] like i said
most people i think that's as far as it
would go
i mean that it just goes to show that
like armin maivas
he puts the ad in there saying outright
you know i'm looking for an 18 to 35
year old well-built male and i want to
kill and eat him
and he goes out there and says that and
he got more than one person
to respond and most of them backed out
because i feel like once they thought
about it they were like oh this is real
i don't really want to do that now you
see
ian b he's in the comments he's in he's
in the comment sections
and i don't know if he's [ __ ] with me
or not but he's saying the drop in lead
seems to have reduced serial killers
i've been saying that [ __ ] for [ __ ]
months yeah i think he knows he's busy
that's probably a great factor too when
they got rid of that leaded gasoline
i noticed that [ __ ] [ __ ] got better
and i remember going to the damn
gasoline pump and getting leaded
gasoline or unleaded gasoline and put it
in a car i'd run both
when you run [ __ ] leaded gasoline
through a car it doesn't destroy those
lead particles it blows them right out
the [ __ ] tail pipe
well yeah catalytic converter or not
didn't [ __ ] matter
well what happened with those lead
particles we breathed them in and gave
them
brain damage and they would collect
inside of [ __ ] cities
and places where people were and people
did some weird
[ __ ] man it's like some stuff on on on
the level of the roman empire stuff
well what was rome doing they had lead
water pipes and they were eating off of
lead plates
drinking out of lead cups they were
cutting meat on lead plates
and eating lead particles because they
said that lead tasted good
mmm delicious delicious
okay they did some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
and i that's my [ __ ] hypothesis
that's my hypothesis
is that a lot of that weird [ __ ] back in
the 70s and the 80s had to do with the
lead build up leg contamination
might have been i think so that led
those lead particles would have gotten
down to the water table and everything
well yeah it would have contaminated
everything
yeah that totally explains detroit
totally i was living in that area yeah
all right and and that totally explains
it
[ __ ] leaded gasoline and all that
[ __ ] industrial [ __ ] activity that
was going on
well yeah those [ __ ] people at
michigan are [ __ ] crazy
michigan michiganders are [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
lead [ __ ] poisoned [ __ ] all
of you
everybody that's it everybody in
michigan
yeah bunch of retards
my stepdad was from michigan he was a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm just [ __ ] around because my best
friend was [ __ ] michigan too man the
[ __ ] was
steve i gotta have steve on the show one
of these days
i grew up with steve steve got a
doctorate from [ __ ] university of
michigan he's a genetic
scientist yeah that's right dumb
[ __ ] like me with best friends
with [ __ ] genetic scientists
and he was on that human genome i'm just
kidding i'm not dumb i just that's
that's my cover but uh he was on that
human genome project
and he told me a lot of stuff about that
human genome project that was never made
never made public about what they found
out about the human genome
yeah but yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
they were all aliens no nothing as fun
as that
no it's just that they know a lot more
about humans than they [ __ ] want to
let on
yeah and they don't like us too much
i don't like us either yeah
humans kind of blow yeah i open my next
life i'm a cat
yeah humans are kind of um
uh [ __ ] but i might have i'm gonna i'm
gonna
have to ask steve about lynn
and lead boy isn't it he probably knows
about it
he probably knows about it he probably
knows about it
he's running his software company
another weird thing you know what i mean
this is a [ __ ] weird show
my granddad being in jpl you know from
jet propulsion laboratory and [ __ ]
[ __ ] around with the f-14 tomcat and
the [ __ ] saturn v rocket the moon
mission
and [ __ ] like that my best friend
also on the human genome project all
these smart [ __ ] that
gravitated around the ross
but that dude also the rock st
the ross yeah it's like the font
steve steve made a [ __ ] flight
simulator
a flight simulation program for [ __ ]
computers back in the day
and the fbi [ __ ] [ __ ] came and
invested it has
investigated his ass behind that flight
simulation program because that was the
one
that was the flight simulation program
that the 911 attackers used
to run into that i remember you telling
me yeah run into those damn twin towers
but of course they quickly found it you
know they were like yeah you didn't have
anything to do with that
well i mean a flight simulator is a
flight simulator
i kind of feel like yeah steve does
software now
god damn i'm getting hungry are you
having problems getting hungry again
yeah but i am too kind
but yeah that flight student at a
program so i got all kinds of weird
stories that have never really been on
the show besides all the polish guys
stuff
um we gotta have steve on one of these
times that [ __ ] you guys should
[ __ ] travel he talked about me when i
was a [ __ ] kid he
used to call me [ __ ] mild cheese
that's right
bald cheese yeah although i don't i
don't remember why he called you that
though machismo
he's making fun of me and [ __ ] making
fun of my mom
called her margie the two g's for the
double g
breasts my mom had big ass i would have
showed some pictures of my mom when she
was young you guys understand my mom
looked like cassandra peterson
and he used to [ __ ] with me and says you
know i [ __ ] your mom i was like what
cause yeah i [ __ ] your mom he's
[ __ ] with you
so then i still reflect with him by
[ __ ] his sister
[Laughter]
did he have a sister i thought yeah he
had a sister yeah oh i thought he just
had that brother
no no he had a sister too dwayne paul
yeah no no that was a justin
i [ __ ] had a little [ __ ] mouth you
might dwean paul
like this funny [ __ ] voice no he had
a sister that was younger than him but
older than than than googs good yeah
we called him googs yeah yeah yeah and
uh
but she wasn't she was just getting into
high school when i when i
when i was retaliating by saying that i
[ __ ] her yeah
yeah so it wasn't that date rapey
no she was only like two two or three
years younger oh okay so it's
it's legit yeah yeah
no statutory stuff no no no okay no
i was still in high school she was the
freshman i was [ __ ] the junior or
something
i used to threaten him i used to
threaten him behind that you were gonna
do that that was gonna [ __ ] you
probably totally would have done that
well i only pulled that out of my
[ __ ] back pocket when he was saying
that it was he that he was [ __ ] my
mom
and i said you should have said you
[ __ ] his mom oh no that wouldn't have
been a trophy there no that would happen
yeah i don't know what his mom looked
like so i don't know so he's been
pulling i said well you know i [ __ ]
your sister
he's like dude you didn't do that did he
just yeah i did i'd be lying my ass off
but you're dealing with [ __ ] dudes
okay
you gotta understand the [ __ ] you
gotta put this in the context of the
times
okay we were basically kind of like
something out of [ __ ] bill and ted's
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] bill ted's [ __ ]
adventure yeah i can see that it was
like that
we we were like that i [ __ ] your mom
yeah yeah yeah
i [ __ ] your mind yeah i [ __ ] your
sister you didn't [ __ ] my sister yeah i
did
yeah i was trying to convince grandma i
was trying to convince him that i [ __ ]
his sister
and then he tried to convince me that he
found my mom
[Laughter]
that's how crazy it was back then man
these are weird that's how [ __ ] crazy
it was that [ __ ] was like 1980
that was like 1986 1987 around that time
were [ __ ] weird just
you don't understand the way it was
that's just what it was
he always i gotta consult these
[ __ ] he always says that like
like i wasn't
there too yeah you know what he did the
other day
this like we all know tom was well fed
baby yes
yes it was remember that 70s film
prophecy about lead poison bear killing
people i do indeed remember that movie
i do um i just saw i think it was on
oh [ __ ] i saw it on 2b or somewhere
or shut her at it or something because i
remember just seeing the card the other
day and being like oh man i should watch
that
because i haven't seen that in such a
long time but yeah you want
he always like he always says stuff like
that i don't remember
like oh you don't know how it was you
don't know but he's only like two years
older than me yeah but i'm a man
right but he had brothers so you kind of
know yeah i have two brothers i saw that
[ __ ] first person though
i know but yeah i know and i had a lot
of friends over dudes too
like when i was that age so it's like i
know he's like i don't know you're so
weird
yes like yesterday part of it is my
stick i gotta [ __ ] with you oh yeah
yesterday the day before i was like i
was sitting in the bathroom like in
front of my makeup here and i was
brushing my hair
and he comes over there and he's like
get look look get the back there's knots
i'm like dude
i've had this hair for 48 years
i can brush my own i was trying to brush
it
he was talking like i never brushed my
own hair before
like look you're messing it up i'm like
i know i know how to brush my [ __ ]
hair
what are you doing damn it's like crazy
it's crazy
you know what time it is it's uh time to
go eat something it's time to go eat
something to shut this [ __ ] down yeah
cause we've been on what
we've been on three hours and 11 minutes
yeah it's about time
three hours that's good that's pretty
good oh yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed
the show today
we had a good time yeah i was like i was
worried at the
at first because i never used this
program and i didn't know it was going
to happen like when i pushed all the
buttons
yeah but you know it looked like it's
working it looked like it did okay
looks like it's doing good so you know
hopefully uh from now on we'll have
all this snazzy [ __ ] yeah and you
can always add to more to the little
video things and [ __ ] we can do some
fun [ __ ] there well i mean i can't get
too crazy i don't want 50 million things
you can do different little ticker tapes
in there you know you need need to add
for our shirts and our [ __ ]
merchandise in there well the zazzle
thing is on
it's right there okay see okay
and then you could like uh yeah or
whatever all right
all right so you guys enjoyed the show
yeah i hope you guys did too thank you
everybody stopped by everybody that
contributed
we had a really good time oh man i'm
really i'm kind of getting messed up at
this point yeah
all right so we we kind of covered the
cases that's that's good
as long as we get through my notes i'm
usually like okay that's fine
yeah they enjoy the show so remember if
you like the show like share subscribe
on all your social media oh
tom dropped his glasses and uh if you'd
like to financially support the show be
much appreciating go to our patreon page
patreon.com
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
link 13 o'clock
our blog rather 13 o'clock
podcast.wordpress.com and there's a
button in the sidebar that goes to a
paypal account
if you'd like to give a one-time
donation also much appreciated i wrote
down everybody's uh name that wanted a
t-shirt this time around i think there's
a couple people that wanted to teach you
contact her on facebook
so yeah just uh throw me a facebook
message or
instagram or something like that with a
size and
mailing address if i don't have it and
all that other kind of stuff and it
might be a week or two before we get to
it because i got to order some blanks
uh so but we'll get it all sorted out in
the end
so uh we'll probably stream again
tomorrow at some point either a movie
review or side tracks we'll see
what we're doing c is out here so uh
yeah oh i missed it yeah sorry we just
we've been on since five
yeah oh well um but yeah so
uh we will see you guys tomorrow uh